ps pourrait devenir de moins en moins
fiables internet auquel nous sommes tous
tellement habitués pourrait
dysfonctionné et perdre en vitesse nous
gadget préféré le confort de la haute
technologie
tout cela pourrait devenir totalement
inutilisable
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
coups politiques n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la veille les idées courageuse
des mots qui comptent en soi vient des
guignols
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrêmement
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi l'essentiel de l'information
avec nos invités en plateau et nos
reporters sur le terrain voici les
grands titres de l'actualité de ce mardi
21 janvier la lumière food in vient de
dévoiler la composition du nouveau
gouvernement russe
les poids lourds sakai lavrov et sergueï
choïgou conservent leur portefeuille des
affaires étrangères et de la défense
le président us a souhaité le succès
cette nouvelle équipe dirigée par
mireille mitch austin c'est parti pour
le procès historique en destitution de
donald trump pour abus de pouvoir et
obstruction les débats sont ouverts à un
procès sans accusé puisque le président
américain lui et à davos pour assister
au forum économique mondial
les démocrates dénoncent un calendrier
imposé et pourra quitter au plus vite le
président des états unis
la loi contre la cyberhaine acte iii à
l'assemblée nationale le sénat et le
retour au palais bourbon pour ce texte
dont la mesure la plus polémique a été
réintroduite il s'agit de l'obligation
pour les réseaux sociaux de retirer sous
24 heures les contenus haineux son pêne
d'une grosse amende
[Musique]
on connaît donc depuis 18h heure
française le visage du nouveau
gouvernement russe 12 ministres au total
conservent leur poste à l'instar des
poids lourds sergueï lavrov et sergueï
choïgou mais on compte aussi du sang
neuf le point avec antoine claireaux en
direct de moscou bonsoir antoine essayer
le pouvoir russe dispose donc d'un tout
nouveau gouvernement un premier conseil
des ministres s'est tenu comment cela
s'est déroulé oui bien c'est le
président russe vladimir poutine qui a
ouvert qui est inauguré en compagnie de
son premier ministre michail michou
steen ce conseil des ministres nouvelle
génération à commencer par a félicité la
nomination des nouveaux venus tout en
rendant hommage au travail fourni par
l'ancienne équipe
un travail qu'il faudra désormais
poursuivre écouter le gouvernement
précédent a fait beaucoup pour
poursuivre le développement premièrement
les conditions macroéconomiques ont été
instaurées et ça c'est très important
et bien évidemment sans cela il n'y
aurait aucun résultat après tout ce qui
a été obtenu grâce à un travail
important et doit être exploitée pour
l'avenir
pour parvenir au résultat d'intérêt
national et utiliser les instruments
qu'ils étaient construits qui ont été
mises en place notamment pour les grands
projets donc le précédent gouvernement à
travailler là dessus il a mis en place
des instruments qui sont utiles et seuls
ceux là encore une fois va dans
l'intérêt du pays et la priorité c'est
bien évidemment du d'améliorer le
bien-être de la population
et tout cela ce sont des objectifs qui
sont tout à fait réalistes
encore une fois je vous souhaite bonne
chance et je suis convaincu que vous
ferez tout votre possible pour que nous
puissions parvenir aux objectifs qui ont
été fixés
parmi les ministres à avoir conservé
leur portefeuille
on dénombre donc sergueï lavrov aux
affaires étrangères ou encore sergueï
choïgou à la défense c'est donc la
continuité qui a été préféré pour ces
deux ministères autant important que
sensible autres ministres avoir déjà été
présents dans le gouvernement précédent
alexandre novak ministre de l'énergie
qui va pouvoir continuer à superviser
l'achèvement des travaux du gazoduc nord
stream ii ou encore le renouvellement
des différents contrats gaziers parmi
les nouvelles têtes on peut citer oleg
ma titine à la ministère des sports qui
lui hérite du dossier épineux des
accusations de dopage à l'encontre du
sport russe qui a valu à la russie une
interdiction de se rendre aux
compétitions pour une durée de quatre
ans il ya encore maxime reshetnikov qui
remplace maxime orechkine à l'économie
c'est donc un savant mélange
d'expérience et de nouveautés de
continuité et de renouvellement qui va
devoir maintenant gouverner la russie
merci antoine clairon en direct depuis
moscou et pour en parler
nous sommes en direct avec claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude qui prend
place
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france
ce nouveau gouvernement annoncé donc par
vladimir poutine avec des nouveaux
membres qui sont connus à quoi va-t-il
ressembler surtout qu'est ce que cela
traduit quelle ambition
moi je crois renouvellement et
continuité et naturellement le premier
suit même marque un renouvellement avec
quelqu'un qui est apprécié dans toute la
fonction publique russe commun un très
bon spécialiste des questions fiscales
et des questions économiques
et je note d'ailleurs que le bloc
économique du gouvernement n'a pas
beaucoup changé
parmi les ministres qui est qui reste
des douze ministres qui reste il y a le
ministre des finances il y a le ministre
de l'industrie et du commerce il y a le
ministre de l'agriculture
il y a aussi d'autres d'autres ministres
et par conséquent le bloc économique
reste à thé intégral
le bloc sécuritaire aussi puisque
monsieur choïgou reste vis de la défense
le milieu intérieur reste remise
intérieure est le troisième dont on ne
parle pas très souvent chez nous mais
c'est important
en russie c'est le ministère des
situations d'urgence pour toutes les
catastrophes ou pour tous les attentats
c'est aussi un accord militarisé qui a
son importance et le ministre des
situations d'urgence
reste le même alors je crois qu'on ait
fait ça c'est là les poules de stabilité
les piliers avec naturellement monsieur
lavrov pour la politique étrangère bien
entendu que je cite an dernier mais qu
on aurait pu citer en premier puisque
c'était un pilier majeur
et puis les autres changent alors il ya
quand même 16 ministres qui change c'est
beaucoup et notamment tout le secteur
social le ministre de la culture change
il était assez contesté notamment par
les milieux culturels et intellectuels
il change peut-être tant mieux et puis
le mil ministre qui s'occupe de la santé
c'est une revendication très importante
dans les questions posées au président
au mois de décembre y avait beaucoup de
questions qui portaient sur les
problèmes de gestion de la santé
publique
et puis le ministère d'éducation
naturellement qu'ils changent aussi
demain le mystère l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche qui
changent de mains c'est l'avenir de la
russie qui se joue là dans ces deux
ministères est-ce que c'est exact
finalement de dire ce qui change le plus
c'est ce qui est à ferran au peuple
vraiment la gestion quotidienne et
garde les têtes finalement connu les
poids lourds pour ce qui est de
l'extérieur l'international oui je crois
je crois que c'est ça on pour le pôle
international pour les ministères de
force et aussi pour l'économie mais
enfin la d'économie c'est aussi très
important
monsieur poutine à tout à l'heure
souligné que le cadre macroéconomique
était bon qu'il fallait l'exploiter et
en effet en particulier l'exploiter en
rendant efficace les les plans qui ont
été faits notamment les plans les 15
grands projets nationaux qui ont été
faits pour l'infrastructure vaut aussi
pour les secteurs prioritaires comme
l'éducation et la santé
et donc ces plans devraient enfin
décoller avec ce gouvernement
alors vladimir poutine a rendu hier à la
série d'amendements constitutionnels
qu'il souhaite soumettre au vote des
députés qu'est-ce qu'on peut on retenir
quel changement
alors si très important on voit que les
amendements étaient soumis très
rapidement après leurs annonces
allah
la douma et au haut conseil de la
fédération réunis il était donc
probablement près puisqu'ils sont
arrivés très rapidement ensuite à la
douma
ça veut dire que monsieur poutine veut
aller vite pour mener à bien cette
réforme constitutionnelle donc y aura
sans doute des discussions dans les deux
champs il a dit aussi qu'il voulait
consulter la population
la constitution russe ne prévoit pas le
référendum donc il faudra trouver un
mode de consultation adoptent qu elle
semblera peut-être un référendum mais
qu'ils n'en sera pas puisqu'il n'y en a
pas dans la constitution russe
et puis le contenu même de ces
amendements et bien c'est un contenu
assez important puisque après la réforme
c'est la douma qui va désigner le
premier ministre et qui va désigner
chacun des membres du gouvernement
ça veut dire que la douma qui va être
élu à l'automne 2021 donc dans 18 mois
aura de nouveaux pouvoirs et que c'est
elle qui aura la légitimité pour
désigner le premier ministre et le
gouvernement
ce qui me fait dire peut-être me soulage
démenti par les faits que le
gouvernement actuel est un gouvernement
de transition de transition entre le
dispositif actuel et le dispositif qui
sera mis en place par la nouvelle
constitution et qui sera effectif après
l'élection de la prochaine douma et donc
plus clairement de pouvoir pour ce
parlement est peut-être plus de
démocratie on peut le résumer un fou oui
bien sûr ça veut dire que le parlement
aura la possibilité de s'emparer d'un
certain nombre de sujets et d'en
débattre
vraiment mais ça dépend aussi des
parlementaires il faut que les
parlementaires se saisissent des sujets
et le courage d'avoir des discussions
les discussion contradictoire
ça suppose aussi qu'on fasse une place à
l'opposition parce qu'ils aient pas de
discussions fructueuses en ra parlement
qu'il n'y a pas d'opposition
donc ça suppose en effet une évolution
institutionnelle que monsieur poutine
semble a appelé de ses voeux
en dix ans le pays est mûr pour cette
évolution institutionnelle c'est ce
qu'il a dit le 15 janvier alors un
article retient l'attention celui
concernant le conseil d'état une
institution qui pourrait permettre à
vladimir poutine de rester au pouvoir au
delà de
de 2024 on dit beaucoup de choses on dit
que il pourrait aussi être premier
ministre
moi je n'y crois pas beaucoup le futur
premier ministre sera désigné par la
douma et surtout pour s'occuper de
questions économiques et sociales
on dit aussi qu'il pourrait présider un
conseil de sécurité un peu un peu
revampé un peu de paix je n'y crois pas
beaucoup non plus parce que c'est la
solution qui a été adopté au kazakhstan
par monsieur nous sommes donc sous le
temps nazarbaïev et je suis pas sûr que
ce soit nécessairement l'exemple que
veulent suivre monsieur poutine alors
effectivement hier et solutions de la
présidence du conseil d'état mais
actuellement le conseil d'état c'est la
réunion des gouverneurs plus des
personnalités qualifiées désignées par
le gouvernement en fonction de leurs
qualifications
un peu comme chez nous le conseil
économique social et environnemental
donc il faudrait vraiment il c'est un
conseil consultatif donc il faudrait
vraiment le changer beaucoup pour que ce
soit un corps qui ce que se prête à une
présidence poutine après 2024
merci beaucoup au club de maisons expert
en relations internationales d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur arte france on
vous retrouvera d'ailleurs dans notre
édition de 21h
avocat de donald trump interpellé hier
le sénat américain je cite à à quitter
immédiatement le 45e président des états
unis
retour en images sur les principales
caractéristiques de ce procès historique
[Musique]
mais quel enjeu si ce procès n'a aucune
chance d'aboutir à une destitution face
à la majorité sénatoriale républicaine
éléments de réponse avec pierre guerlain
professeur émérite de civilisation
américaine à l'université paris ouest
nanterre
les enjeux du procès je n'ai pas la
défense nationale des états unis
ce n'est pas est-ce que tempête un
menteur ou pas tschopp est un criminel
avéré sûr dans de nombreux plans et les
démocrates ne font pas son procès par
exemple sur son assassinat ciblé illégal
de souleymane sy sur son soutien
massacra au yémen sur ce qui se passait
la frontière avec le mexique
ils ont choisi quelque chose de très
très très bas et 3 qui est bon il a
effectivement les documents qui peuvent
sortir montreront qu'effectivement il a
tenté d'exercer une pression sur
zelensky pour avoir un avantage dans la
campagne à venir
mais dans le schéma général la politique
américaine c'est un tout petit détail et
les énormes crimes qui sont commis
ailleurs sont commis avec la complicité
des démocrates qui votent les crédits
militaires
donc on a un théâtre de l'absurde sur un
petit phénomène est donc tom se
considère effectivement au dessus des
lois mais dans de nombreux domaines dans
lesquels les démocrates ne le chatouille
pas et ce procès historique de donald
trump qui vient donc de débuter à
washington avec l'ouverture des débats
au sénat alors que républicains et
démocrates s'affrontent sur des
questions de procédure le président
américain n'est pas présent au procès il
est embourbé au coeur d'un scandale un
coup de téléphone en juillet dernier
nos homologues ukrainiens ils auraient
demandé lors de ce coup de téléphone une
enquête sur joe biden son adversaire
démocrate on retrouve sur place doha à
del raziq
bonsoir doha quelles sont les dernières
informations avec ce procès qui vient
donc de s'ouvrir à washington eh bien
les yeux de l'amérique mais aussi du
monde sont rivés vers le congrès le
capitole plus précisément le siège du
congrès ici à washington où se déroule
ce procès en destitution de donald trump
est un procès historique c'est le
troisième président de l'histoire des
états unis à se retrouver confronté à
cette procédure d' impeachment vous
l'avais dit au coeur de la faire un coup
de fil donald trump aurait demandé à son
homologue ukrainien est bien de l'aider
à discréditer son potentiel rival à la
présidentielle joe biden on les change
de l'octroi d'une aide militaire alors
il faut savoir que la bataille s'annonce
féroce au vu de ce qui s'est passé il y
environ une heure car il faut savoir que
cette procédure de destitution va se
dérouler en plusieurs étapes
aujourd'hui en fait les sénateurs
doivent déterminer le calendrier des
débats comment cette procédure va avoir
lieu dans les prochains jours il y a
donc 100 sénateurs qui sont présents des
démocrates mais aussi des républicains
et hier soir et bien les républicains
ont présenté la procédure à suivre
à savoir deux blocs de 12 heures pour
l'accusation mais aussi autant pour la
défense puis viendra autour des
questions des sénateurs
mais cette procédure elle fait déjà
débat les démocrates ne veulent pas ils
jugent ce temps beaucoup trop court le
procès pourrait ainsi être bouclée en
deux semaines
donald trump lui est accusé par la
chambre des représentants d' abus de
pouvoir et entrave à la bonne marche du
congrès donc ça sera la première étape
aujourd'hui à savoir donc le calendrier
qui va fixer les règles du jeu puis
viendra ensuite la phase concernant les
témoins celle ci se fera par vote les
démocrates veulent que plusieurs témoins
assistent à ce procès un vote qui
n'inquiète pas donald trump qui
n'inquiète pas
d'ailleurs le président américain tout
court un ce procès puisque vous l'avez
dit donald trump est actuellement à
davos où il assiste au forum économique
mondial
il a une nouvelle fois qualifié ce
procès de chasse aux sorcières de farce
mais le démocrate
adam schiff qui porte justement
l'accusation va tout faire pour essayer
d'allonger la procédure de ce projet de
ce procès par exemple pardon vous qui se
déroule un petit peu plus longtemps
donc nous allons suivre de près
aujourd'hui ses débats au congrès et
puis nous verrons demain comment vont
s'organiser et bien cette accusation
avec les témoins qui devrait comparaître
à ce procès en destitution de donald
trump
merci doha en direct donc de washington
et pour en parler nous sommes maintenant
avec eric bana membres des républicaine
c'est une france
bonsoir eric souad merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france
donald trump qui qualifie donc le procès
depuis davos de farce et de chasse aux
sorcières son discours à ne change
absolument pas il garde la même posture
et il a absolument raison
la meilleure citation de donald trump
que j'ai jamais entendu de ma vie en
tout cas pendant l'été présidence et ce
n'est pas après moi qu'ils en ont c'est
après vous le peuple américain et moi je
suis juste
je fais juste obstacles et ce qu'ils
veulent et les gauchistes c'est comme
dans tous les pays gauchistes c'est
pouvoir utiliser toutes les
administrations et tous les tous les
tous les procès tous les justes pour
pour eux faire faire taire le peuple
j'ai toujours dit que le tronc paléo
gagner des guerres républicain on allait
gagner
il ya eu le mariage gay et qu'ils ont
légué gérer un contreur
quand ils ont commencé à faire des
procès contre 1
une personne après l'autre un boulanger
un photographe cédera les américains
sont pas extrémistes ils en ont il veut
juste qu'on les laisse tranquilles comme
disait le drapeau
américain pendant la révolution de 1776
d'entraînement laissez nous tranquilles
et j'aimais bien de faux dans certains
cas ce qu'a dit le professeur de
nanterre tout à l'heure puisqu'il a dit
c'est un criminel
voilà ce que mon les gauchistes que ce
soit de staline mao
maintenant ils viennent en amérique ils
voient tous les peuples comme des
criminels ou des incapables
il faut absolument que les les
politiciens et les bureaucrates s'occupe
de ces personnes alors vous le savez les
démocrates ont accusé les républicains
de vouloir organiser un procès en
destitution je cite truquée de donald
trump au sénat américain avec vous
l'avez suivi évidemment un calendrier
imposé pour acquitter distille au plus
vite le président des états unis est ce
que vous réfute évidemment cette
accusation il ya un peu de vrai quand
même et c'est peut-être de bonne guerre
l'essai n'a choisi ses propres à ses
propres règles internes comme la maison
de représentants choisis ses propres
failles d'un terne
si on veut discuter sur 30 pour ceux ci
ce qui est historique avec ce procès
c'est que à partir de maintenant tous
les présidents qu'ils soient démocrates
républicains indépendants quoiqu'il soit
pourront avoir des procès interminables
les bush et clinton obama tout le monde
aurait pu être avoir un alpage fête avec
les copains avec ce qu'ont dit les
démocrates et on oublie souvent que
comme bayrou l'a bien dit il ya une
vidéo de we lui dit j'ai avant de
quitter l'ukraine je veux que vous vous
débarrassez de se procurer d'un certain
procureur sinon vous n'aurez pas les 6
milliards de dollars promis donc le
président a aussi le droit qu'ils soient
démocrates ou républicains de se savoir
ce qu'il en est et s'il ya eu des pots
de vin et de la corruption
il en est tout à fait certain et
enturbannés qu'un des cinq membres du
dasani de bannu qui a cassé
qui est devenu riche grâce à leur père
leur oncle cousin etc
c'est une bonne chose quand même selon
vous ce procès qui va se dérouler au pas
de charge plutôt un de bonne augure pour
abattre moi je suis ravi moi je suis
ravi souvenez-vous les temps les
démocrates que les républicains 30 comme
ceux qui sont contre lui peut choisir
les les commandes étaient moins qu'ils
veulent ils pourraient faire venir
drogba ou feraient preuve pourrait faire
venir son père il pourrait finir faire
venir
gary clinton bill clinton pourquoi pas
obama
on s'est pas dites parlez nous de cette
histoire de la deûle à l'espionnage qui
a vu sur le sur le le parti républicain
en 2016 et parlez nous dit s milliard et
parlez nous de la cia qui ont été
complètement prise à des prix qui sont
complètement dans le dans le camp d'un
seul parti les démocrates et comment
c'est censé être un des policiers qui
sont neutres et objectifs alors l'un des
avocats de donald trump a assuré kenneth
starr on connaît évidemment son nom wii
jusqu'à la france hier au curragh de la
sphère levinsky aujourd'hui avocat de la
défense ancien avocat dodji simpson et
de jeffrey epstein c'est une équipe de
changer ça va être un petit peu le le
feuilleton qu'il faut suivre aux états
unis bah oui je pense qu'on va bien
s'amuser au trot il et il n'est pas
aussi bête que les européens veulent
bien le poids il est démocrate et il
prépare une contre offensive sur tout
les toutes tes attaques souligne qu'il a
eu il a subi depuis trois quatre ans il
va il va les renvoyer dans le visage des
démocrates et avec raison
je sais pas si vous avez vu la réaction
de winch est justement là carwin ce qui
c'est je vais le dire en anglais parce
que je sinon ce sera peut-être pas
acceptable c'est une fausse idée mais je
te voir revoir star tout le monde
l'année où
vous pensez qu'il était mort pour faire
je savais pas effectivement pas besoin
de traduction on a tous compris un tel
impact à votre avis vous avez dit oui ça
va être un petit peu le feuilleton on va
bien s'amuser
quel impact justement sur la campagne
présidentielle de donald trump selon
vous ben il a il est il est certain que
la plupart des américains pensent qu'il
est qu'il est la victime
c'est ici si c'était le première fois
mais ça fait ça fait trois ans qu'on
nous dit répète sans cesse on va le dmp
chez greenpeace et soit c'est pour les
russes plus menacer l'ukraine entre les
deux c'était pour la star du porno story
daniel et les américains là peu neutre
qui sont pas forcément démocrate un
extrémiste il faut il se disait c'est
pas possible
en plus les élus ne sont rien d'autre on
les a vus pour améliorer la vie du
peuple soit avait en conçoit en symbiose
avec donin avec les républicains comme
de notre soin de soi tout seul mais on
dirait qu'ils sont rien d'autre ils sont
obsédés et un autre avis ils ont très
peur de ce qu'il peut pour et se retire
à propos d'app store ce qui est
intéressant c'est que c'est le sexe de
kiara scandale avec le sexe normalement
on se rue dessus comme avec la nascar et
10 donnant au score et di donna trompe
ya une dizaine d'années mais dès qu'ils
voient que ce qui est des démocrates
dans le des gauchistes 10 euros c'est
pas si important que ça il accuse de
natoye bel air est une fière d'être des
des racistes de la virginie qu on a
découvert qu'il s'était mis le 1 des
noirs dans les temps le visage et qu'il
avait portée ou alors qu'il avait porté
un képi duty jacskon mais il s'avère que
c'est un démocrate alors tout le monde à
laisser tomber
c'est là les deux poids deux mesures
c'est incroyable merci à les démocrates
super voir ce party game entre les
piquets d'une certaine manière
c'est les deux poids deux mesures de la
de la société de la presse de l'été fait
news qui était incroyable merci eric
swan membres des républicaine c'est une
france d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur mtv commence dans quelques instants
décrypteront l'actualité politique notre
invité ce soir gaspard gander candidat
indépendant à la mairie de paris
tête de liste parisienne parisien dans
le 15e arrondissement de la capitale et
puis nous reviendrons sur la loi a via
la loi contre la haine en ligne qui
refait son apparition à l'assemblée
nationale
[Musique]
comment ces deux noms n'évoquent pas
seulement le cinéma
ils sont le cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
charles pathé a le génie des affaires
léon gaumont est un ingénieur surdoué
ces deux hommes que tout oppose et se
sont forgé une destinée commune dans une
perpétuelle surenchère ils ont bâti
chacun leur empire et dominer le monde
[Musique]
et
les blanchons les bébés phoques du
groenland naissent sur la banquise de la
mer blanche
tout au long du xxème siècle les bébés
phoques ont été chassés pour leur
fourrure blanche comme neige
depuis que la chasse aux phoques est
interdite en russie il n'y a que les
touristes qui viennent voir ces animaux
à l'état sauvage
mais ces petits seront ils toujours en
sécurité
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ce que six est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette édition du dakar en arabie
saoudite fait parler je pense que le
dakar va faire du bien pour ce qui est
de la découverte du terrain par lui-même
des paysages mais maintenant pour le
reste est justement il faut en débattre
le pays n'a est un bon produit
invendable
j'insiste sur la bande am parce que
justement c'est là que si vous voulez ce
qu'essaye de faire actuellement mohammed
bin salman le prince héritier c'est
d'essayer de modifier à la marge le
l'image de ce pays et vous comprenez
bien que la tâche est ardue
sportivement le pari est gagné mais au
niveau politique c'est pas ça voilà vous
êtes en premier on leur propose d'arabie
saoudite
peut être que beaucoup de sportifs
ignore et puis honnêtement on y va le
fait qu'une manifestation sportive se
déroule dans un pays qui effectivement
que tous les deux les domaines dès qu'on
touche aux pressions des droits de
l'homme et de la femme évidemment bon
effectivement c'est peut-être pas
complètement sans y aller il faut
approfondir et peut-être qu'en ventirad
et enseignements de cette première
édition
mais moi je serais très heureux que ce
soit une femme qui gagne le dakar et
pourquoi pas
[Musique]
20h30 merci nous rejoindre en direct sur
rt france et pour décrypter l'actualité
nous sommes avec gaspard grands airs
candidat indépendant à la mairie de
paris
tête de liste parisienne parisien dans
le 15e arrondissement de la capitale
c'est notre invité politique ce soit
bonsoir gaspard ganzer merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france avant
d'aborder la question des municipal qui
vous intéressent particulièrement
un petit décryptage de l'actualité avec
toujours la réforme des retraites qui
occupent le devant de la scène dans un
climat que l'on sait extrêmement tendue
vastes coupures d'électricité ce matin
encore dans le sud de paris revendiquer
clairement par la cgt énergie qui assume
est-ce que vous cautionnez vous ce genre
d'action pour se faire entendre alors je
ne le cautionne pas et je le condamne
même à ce que je pense que le droit de
grève est un droit constitutionnel en
revanche il est interdit de bloquer soit
le service public des transports soit le
service public de l'eau de l'électricité
du gaz et donc il est inacceptable que
des syndicats où certains membres des
syndicats détourne l'usagé du droit de
grève au profit de ce qui semble être
une atteinte en réalité à la liberté de
chacun normalement je le condamne très
fermement
alors autre bataille dans la bataille
les syndicats entre deux intrusions au
siège de la cgt cfdt pardon revendiquez
toujours par la cgt énergie cette
pression exercée d'un syndicat sur un
autre parce qu'on n'est pas d'accord
là encore une une réaction vous
comprenez que les cégétistes soit à bout
de nerfs aujourd'hui on peut comprendre
la colère des uns et des autres n'ont
pas le temps on ne peut jamais excuser
la violence et l'intrusion chez un autre
syndicat la liberté syndicale est elle
aussi une liberté fondamentale de notre
république liberté syndicale ça veut
dire liberté de tous les syndicats et il
est inacceptable que certains membres
d'un syndicat parce que je veux croire
que la majorité des membres de la cgt ne
sont pas dans cette situation puisse
s'en prendre à des salariés d' à celles
d'été dont j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
témoigner ma solidarité aux salariés et
aux militants de la cfdt je leur fais ce
soit parce que je pense que c'est
inacceptable qu'on s'en prenne à eux
alors en tout cas cette bataille
finalement peu ça a été le cas en tout
cas pour l'assurance chômage bénéficier
au gouvernement qui fait passer une
réforme qui pourtant n'est pas populaire
majoritairement auprès des français
c'est l'analyse que vous en faites à
quel prix alors déjà la réforme n'est
pas encore passé le prénom république
avait annoncé la couleur pour ma
commande présidentielle il avait dit
qu'il voulait une réforme des retraites
dont il a un mandat électoral pour la
mettre en oeuvre ce que l'on peut
regretter c'est que la méthode qui était
adaptée a conduit à sa tombe blocage et
de tensions dans le pays
le président la république et son
gouvernement ont mis du temps mais ils
ont fini par abandonner ou reporter la
mesure de l'âge pivot qui était celle
qui cristallise et les colères dans le
secteur privé et reste le système dit
par points qui conduit à une
universalisation du système de retraites
donc cette réforme peut aller au bout ce
n'est pas encore fait souhaitons que
maintenant on retrouve surtout le calme
et l'apaisement parce que vous savez
pour les usagers notamment les
franciliens les usagers des transports
publics qu'ils soient le métro la sncf
pour tous les franciliens mais aussi
pour tous les français vraiment il ya un
ras-le-bol généralisé moi je sens les
gens tendu épuisé fatigué donc je leur
témoigne ma solidarité parce que
vraiment c'est très fatigant pour les
gens c'est grève qui dure qui dure qui
dure
alors c'est vrai que
on en reçoit évidemment comme chaque
chaîne de télévision sur ce plateau qui
nous disent oui mais la violence elle
est du côté du gouvernement qui veut
nous imposer des lois dont on ne veut
pas qu'ils donnent aux plus riches il ya
une vraie tension est ce qu'elle vous
semble inédite dans le pays on a quand
même vu un président de la république
ciblé 1 ce week-end alors qu'il était au
théâtre
est ce que ça vous inquiète ce climat
extrêmement tendu
oui je ça m'inquiète bien sûr puisqu'il
ya une tension quand même assez inédite
dans l'histoire de la vème république
l'année dernière le mouvement d'idées
gilet jaune avait quand même de la
violence de la casse beaucoup de blessés
des morts est cette année de nouveaux de
la casse des violences
un appel contre l'autorité une remise en
cause de cette autorité
or je pense que dans notre pays on a
besoin d'ordre d'autorité mais aussi de
sécurité et surtout de calme et
d'apaisement j'ai envie que je pense que
les gens ont envie de sortir de cette
phase extrêmement douloureuse ils
comprennent on ait besoin de faire des
réformes
en revanche mais s'interroge sur les
blocages qui sont suscitées par celle ci
ils savent pas s'ils doivent accusé le
gouvernement accusé les syndicats je les
comprends parce que moi même souvent je
me demande qui est le vrai responsable
de tout cela mais comme tout le monde
j'ai envie qu'on retrouve du calme et de
l'apaisement et de l'ordre à nicolas
sarkozy on l'entend dès hier se vanter
un peu avec humour la d'avoir fait
passer plein de réformes dans le calme
vous avez été très proche un responsable
de la communication de françois hollande
est ce que cette tension pour vous elle
est particulièrement lié
à ce gouvernement d' emmanuel macron que
vous connaissez bien vous avez été à
l'école ensemble
est ce que je sais ce gouvernement là où
c'est un cumul de choses et je crois que
tout gouvernement à son moment de
cristallisation des colères c'est arrivé
sous chirac et dont le deuxième mandat
avec le cpe c'était sous le premier
mandat avec les grèves de 95
mais c'était aussi violent relate mais
justement à chaque fois il y avait un
seul rendez vous là déjà il y en a eu
deux on a eu la cristallisation l'année
dernière qui était gagne très violente
et cette année de nouveau donc c'est
assez inédit sous la vème république et
ses cristallisation d'un côté on peut se
dire que c'est parce qu'à une volonté
réformatrice partiellement puis centre
du programme public de notre côté on
peut quand même s'interroger sur la
méthode et peut-être aussi sur l'état du
pays
la france me donne parfois le sentiment
d'être un corps dont la peau a été
retiré à vif et sur lequel on ne peut
pas pratiquer des thérapies de choc il
faut faire attention il faut faire
attention
oui il faut réformer mais il faut le
faire avec intelligence et recherche du
consensus sans forcément à mener un
combat du bien contre le mal
alors emmanuel macron temps en train de
parler de bonnes nouvelles économiques
hier d'une france qui avant avance grâce
aux réformes il exprime hier c'était sa
frustration face à cette période dit il
qu'on voudrait morose il ya du vrai
selon vous dans la parole présidentielle
alors je crois que la situation
économique est meilleure qu'il ya
quelques années il faut le reconnaître
les efforts qui ont été accomplis par
nicolas sarkozy pour sortir de la crise
de 2008 amplifiées par françois hollande
commune à redresser le pays bénéficie
aujourd'hui hélène mathon qui a apporté
sa propre touche personnelle
d'attractivité d'indépendance et
entrepreneuriat tant mieux si la france
va mieux et c'est une vraie bonne
nouvelle
maintenant il faut que ça dure parce
qu'on sent aussi qu'il ya des signes
inquiétants du point de vue de la
conjoncture économique mondiale
en revanche je me méfie toujours qu'on
est chef de l'état commence à dire que
le peuple est trop ceci trop cela je
pense que le rôle du chef de l'état
c'est pas d'être un prof de
développement personnel dans lequel on
accuserait les gens d'avoir des troodon
de négative
le rôle du prince république c'est de
travailler d'être tous les jours à la
tâche mais pas de juger son peuple alors
parmi les tensions on le voit
illustration en tout cas de ces tensions
c'est ce sont ces violences de part et
d'autre sur le terrain les accusations
de violences policières de la part des
manifestants
un ami de l'intérieur et même un
président de la république a rappelé un
petit peu alors d'appeler à plus de
déontologie les partis politiques ps la
france info misère n qui appelle à la
définition du préfet de police de paris
vous êtes concerné par paris est ce que
vous partagez cet appel à la démission
de du préfet l'allemand vous savez moi
j'ai travaillé très longtemps pour
l'état j'ai travaillé aussi pour le
maire de paris bertrand delanoë j'ai
appris quelque chose c'est qu'il ne faut
jamais appelé à la démission des hauts
responsables publics parce qu'ils font
leur maximum pour bien faire leur
travail et on a besoin d'eux à leur
juste place
moi je n'ai pas d'appréciation ce fait
recette aux arbres certainement je n'ai
pas d'appréciation personnelle a porté
sur le travail du préfet de police en
revanche ce que j'observe c'est que
aujourd'hui on l'a vu l'année dernière
il ya des problèmes dans le maintien de
l'ordre de nombreux blessés des moments
on a le sentiment que les forces de
l'ordre étaient débordés et cette année
il ya des images qui nous ont tous
choqués il ya même eu un mort vous savez
qu'à paris cédric joue via est mort à la
suite d'un contrôle d'identité
lorsqu'elle en dehors d'une
manifestation à côté de la tour eiffel
ça c'est quand même totalement inédit
dans les dernières années que quelqu'un
meurt à la suite d'un contrôle
d'identité à la justice me permettra de
savoir ce qui s'est passé mais le
sentiment que l'on a collectivement
c'est que quand même on a une police qui
fait son maximum qui fait d'eux le fait
dans des conditions difficiles mais
parfois il ya des abus du laisser-aller
et peut-être un manque de cadres et
d'autorité moi je ne vise jamais les
policiers individuellement même si
parfois ils peuvent commettre des fautes
en revanche je pense que l'encadrement
comme dans l'armée doit être fort
puissant pour justement éviter ce genre
de bowdam ans pour pas que les policiers
les gendarmes se sentent tout permis
les agents justement c'est vrai que je
sois bien n'ont pas été suspendues au
grand désarroi de la famille pour moi
c'est incompréhensible
c'est incompréhensible que dès que des
agents de police qui font l'objet d'une
procédure judiciaire à l'heure actuelle
puisqu'il ya eu l'ouverture d'une
information judiciaire pour des faits
extrêmement graves
alors que quelqu'un qui est mort n'est
pas été suspendus ils ont droit bien
évidemment à la présomption d'innocence
mais comment est ce que vous pensez
qu'ils puissent aujourd'hui exercer
leurs fonctions
avec une telle procédure judiciaire qui
a été enclenché honnêtement je ne trouve
pas ça dit tout comme je n'ai pas trouvé
digne que
l'intérieur mètres près de deux semaines
pour recevoir la famille de cédric
chevaux via donc une bombe ne leur
ténois une nouvelle fois ma solidarité
parce qu'il ce qui est arrivé était
épouvantable
on en vient aux municipales vous êtes
candidat on l'a dit alors hier sur
france info vous dénonciez une grande
division bon enfin ça n'a échappé à
personne et est fait à m je cite les
égos de côté vous vous adressiez à qui
précisément si on croit deviner
évidemment non mais je comprends un peu
de recul et qu'on regarde les enquêtes
d'opinion qu'il faut toujours prendre
avec un peu de pression parce que ces 17
élections que la compagnie a juste de
commencer véritablement et ça joue au
niveau des arrondissements
qu'est ce qu'on regarde on regarde que
sa grosse caisse qu'on voit c'est que
50% des électeurs parisiens sont contre
ce duel dati hidalgo qu'on nous promet
ils sont sur une zone centrale qui est
une progressiste démocrate écologiste
mais qui est extrêmement divisé
pourquoi parce qu'on a le sentiment
qu'il ya des candidats qui se font une
compétition essentiellement sur des
questions d ego titre cédric villa
gillet bajard niveau personnellement
j'ai peut-être mais le suivi pourtant
j'ai discuté souvent avec l'année avec
toi tu ne chantes pas compris ce qui les
sépare et idéologiquement j'ai toujours
pas compris pourquoi il n'avait pas
réussi à se mettre d'accord
on a l'impression vous savez d'être dans
une cour d'école nom n'est qu'il y en a
un qui a piqué son quatre heures à
l'autre qui veut pas du range et l'un et
l'autre ont oublié la raison de leurs
divisions
ou alors c'est un mauvais remake de
l'album d'astérix la zizanie ou en fait
les gens se font la guerre en permanence
et au final ce sont qui les citoyens qui
trinquent parce qu on pourrait en rire
et j'en ai souri avec vous aujourd'hui
mais en réalité c'est pas drôle pourquoi
parce que quand il ya 50 % des parisiens
qui sont pour le changement pour la
création d'une alternative
le fait qu'ils aient cette division
extrêmes ce n'est pas normal ce n'est
pas souhaitable et c'est pour cela
qu'aujourd'hui il faut faire halte au
feu il ne pas se tromper de combat
le vrai combat on doit l'emporter contre
la maire sortante qui elle a failli dans
ses missions de maire de paris
gaspard grande guerre justement vous ne
trouvez pas enfin vous avez l'habitude
de la politique vous semblez très étonné
par cette guerre
dgo vous voilà pourquoi l'un se
retirerait en faveur de l'autre les
hommes politiques nous ont habitués à
aller jusqu'au bout en général dans
leurs ambitions alors il vous avait pas
chez fait que pendant la campagne
présidentielle de 2017 et le maquereau
avait appelé à faire de la politique
autrement
je trouve que moi j'ai voté pour le
maquereau au premier taux et au deuxième
tour de l'élection présidentielle parce
que ceux présents à public que je
connais bien depuis longtemps je m'ai
fait confiance sur cette possible de
renouvellement démocratique et aqua
j'assiste j'assiste à la caricature de
ce qu'il ya de pire dans la vie
politique traditionnelle ou lol ou dans
la vieille politique comme ils disent et
c'est à dire des querelles d'ego des
scissions internes à des partis et je
vous pourrez montrer du doigt je
pourrais m'en manquait je pourrais m'en
réjouir mais ce que j'observe c'est
qu'en fait ça tue le débat démocratique
à paris et alors que paris est comme une
ville importante en france il n'y a pas
que paris bien évidemment on n'a pas le
droit à ce beau débat sur l'avenir de la
ville je ne sais pas à qui doit
s'adresser emmanuel macron est-ce que
c'est à benjamin grimaud ou est-ce que
c'est à cédric villani
je ne sais pas si l'un doit se retirer
au profit de l'autre mais en réalité
aujourd'hui ce que j'observe c'est
qu'ils sont en train de se tirer vers le
front tous les deux ils sont en train de
couler à pic dans la seine et ils ne
vont jamais s'en relever résultat la
maire de paris risque d'être réélu ce
qui de mon point de vue serait une
catastrophe donc vraiment que le prénom
la république que le premier ministre
je ne sais pas qui à la république en
marche les mettent autour d'une table
moi je suis prêt à faire
monsieur bons offices casques bleus si
c'est nécessaire mais honnêtement qu'ils
arrivent à se retrouver
et peut-être aussi on associe aux david
belliard qui lui aussi veut s'affranchir
de même de la majorité municipale qui a
un vrai projet aux progressistes et
écologistes écologistes et progressiste
et qui peut faire avancer cette ville
justement david bellion isabelle saporta
ancienne chroniqueuse un d'airtel pour
koné avait annoncé le 20 août
faire équipe avec vous un 20 août
dernier
l'envisagent de rejoindre david bellion
qui est crédité d'ailleurs de 1% si je
ne me sens un peu plus la bride à 14,14
dû pas mal j'ai toute ma famille avec
vous je cherchais sur malysz pardonnez
moi une réaction justement sur voilà son
bonnet c'est un peu comme une trahison 1
voilà un parachutage un petit peu utile
vous savez dans la vie il ya la
politique mais il ya surtout l'amitié et
isabelle saporta c'est une personnalité
exceptionnelle que j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer cette année c'est quelqu'un
de convaincu de courageux avec des
convictions extrêmement sincère elle
mais a dit cet après-midi gaspard je
suis toujours avec quoi je veux toujours
qu'on avance ensemble bien évidemment je
veux construire cette alliance pour le
climat comme toi je veux travailler à un
grand rassemblement et elle m'a dit que
les informations du monde qui était
révélée par le monde était fausse et les
a démenties d'ailleurs publiquement donc
vous savez j'ai confiance en elle et je
n'ai pas de raison de ne pas la croire
dernière question la circulaire castaner
un des élus aient l'air qui ont saisi le
conseil d'état une manoeuvre de la part
de la république en marche comme le
dénonce on rappelle pour ceux qui
n'auraient pas suivi décision du
gouvernement de ne plus attribuer un les
nuances politiques aux candidats aux
municipales dans les communes de moins
de 9000 habitants en gros les résultats
de ces communes ne serait donc pas prise
en compte dans les résultats nationaux
vous le dénoncez vous aussi je trouve ça
un peu bizarre honnêtement j'ai du mal à
comprendre pourquoi est ce que le
gouvernement a décidé de faire cette bi
drôle d'innovation ça va pas aider à la
lisibilité du scrutin les journalistes
s'en plaigne bien évidemment parce que
comment est ce qu'on va collectionner
comment est-ce qu'on va mesurer le
rapport de forces
or je pense que quand même la politique
a besoin de clarté mais vous savez on
risque de se retrouver dans le syndrome
dit de l'arroseur arrosé parce que si le
gouvernement ait essayé de faire des
magouilles pour cacher les résultats des
élections municipales des citoyens ne
s'y tromperont pas ils affirmeront
fortement dans chaque ville une vision
très claire de ce qu'il souhaite faire
pour l'avenir
merci beaucoup d'adversaires d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle peut-être candidat
indépendant la mairie de paris tête de
liste parisi
n parisien dans le 15e arrondissement si
vous percez on en vient aux gaffes a qui
sont à l'ordre du jour entre paris et
washington c'est la même chose à
l'assemblée nationale vidée de sa
substance par le sénat en décembre et
après l'échec de la commission mixte
paritaire du 8 janvier la loi via contre
l'aèdes en ligne fait son retour au
palais bourbon certains députés
s'interrogent encore sur l'utilité de ce
texte
c'est une loi là aussi pour faire taire
l'opinion mais vous savez c'est un
pouvoir faible autocratique malsain qui
divisait français et qui s'aiment
qui sème le vent et qui récolte la
tempête et c'est malsain pour le pays
moi je souhaite qu'on apaise les choses
et et c'est terrible ce qui se passe
mais il ya un moment un autre bain on en
sortira mais dans quel état
dans quel état le pays ou celles plus
tristes et pour le pays dans tout ça
c'est pas nous on va s'abstenir sur
cette loi la majorité du groupe de
s'abstenir
moi je la trouve pas si mauvaise mais
c'est vrai qu'elle comporte des dangers
et en plus je crois qu'elles soient
inutilisables car d'abord elle est
réelle et très compliqué je suis pas sûr
que les gars femmes jouent le jeu
complètement je tue patio connais
suffisamment de magistrats pour juger et
là on risque de tomber dans une suite
une suite de problèmes qu'on n'arrivera
pas à régler c'est une loi dans
l'intention est bonne mais dont la
réalisation est mauvaise moi je
m'abstiendrai sur ce texte parce que
j'ai le sentiment qu'il ya une intention
de vouloir faire les choses mais vous
savez très bien qu'une directive
européenne qui doit intervenir
majoritairement le groupe liberté et
territoires vote raconte moi je
m'abstiendrai pourquoi parce qu'on peut
pas laisser des façon impunie au titre
de la liberté d'expression laissé
proférer n'importe quel type de message
voilà et là tu reconnaissons le il ya
une forme d'impuissance public
incapacité à faire en sorte que on
arrête ces propos un jour antisémite
deuxième jour appelant au terrorisme le
troisième jour ne sait pas encore où
vraiment c'est la haine et la violence
qui est véhiculée au quotidien la
réponse judiciaire mais elle est pas
suffisamment judiciaire
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
vanessa bouchard avocat spécialiste en
droit de la propriété intellectuelle
bonsoir vanessa bouchara merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france on
voit que c'est compliqué avec cette loi
elle repeint en discussion et ne fait
toujours pas l'unanimité très critiquée
d'ailleurs de la part de la commission
des lois pourquoi est ce si grand bras
de fer à votre avis alors ce qui est
compliqué c'est qu'on met à la charge
des plateformes une un délai extrêmement
court pour bloquer un certain nombre de
contenus selon des critères qui sont
parfois peu défini et ça peut ça peut
créer une sorte de d'incertitude et
l'incertitude n'est jamais n'est jamais
n'est jamais sécurisante pour les
différents acteurs du marché alors de
quel incertitudes vous parler
précisément justement en réalité qu'est
ce qu'on appelle qu'est ce qu'on appelle
contenu qui qui est susceptible d'être
considérée comme et ne sait tout ce qui
est contenu susceptible de porter
atteinte à la dignité humaine donc on a
un grand nombre de 2,2 de choses qui
rentrent dans cette acception et dans
ces conditions ça veut dire que de
manière très large les plateformes
auront une obligation de bloquer des
contenus qui seront susceptibles d'une
manière ou d'une autre de porter
atteinte à la dignité humaine qui est
essentiel et est un qui est quelque
chose de fondamental
justement c'est cette notion un très
critiquée les députés ont rétabli un
justement les réseaux sociaux ce sont à
eux de retirer en moins de 24 heures les
contenus manifestement haineux ça veut
dire qu'on fait peser cette
responsabilité sur des réseaux sociaux
qui vont devenir ainsi les chercheurs
que les réseaux sociaux c'est aussi
notamment les gaffes a donc vous avez
par exemple google qui est astreint à
ces règles ou alors vous aurez
associative et youtube donc en fait on
s'est quand même assez large et
effectivement on fait peser sur eux une
responsabilité très importante avec des
sanctions un corollaire de sanctions
très important aussi et ce qui est
principalement des criées c'est qu'en
réalité on se dit et quel est le rôle du
juge et quel est le rôle qu'on veut
donner assez assez plate forme et est ce
qu'il y aura un arbitrage à un moment
donné si les plateformes faisais
n'importe quoi est ce que ce dernier
sega favori voilà au sens large ces
réseaux sociaux sont ils prêts justement
à exercer ce relais aux censeurs comment
peuvent-ils finalement se préparer à
cela la question est intéressant parce
que chacun de ces deux c'est chacune de
ces plateformes a déjà des règles
internes donc en fait vous avez déjà par
souvent de l'intelligence artificielle
des mots qui sont bloqués
on ne peut pas forcément de utiliser
tous les maux sur l'ensemble de ses
plateformes mais ça leur met ça leur
rajoute à l'heure
règles internes des règles qui
finalement résulte de la législation et
qui s'imposeront à eux avec des
sanctions extrêmement forte si elles ne
sont pas respectées et la question aussi
qui se pose c'est est-ce que ces
plateformes seront en mesure de faire
intervenir des humains sur la la la la
le retrait de contenu on un délai aussi
bref à savoir en 24 heures c'est pas
certains peut-être qu'effectivement il y
aura que l'intelligence artificielle est
peut-être finalement d d d d d
appréhension des visions qui seront pas
forcément les bonnes alors les
détracteurs du texte estiment qui a
également un grand risque pour la
liberté d'expression quel est vraiment
apparu entend d'une part les coûts de
censure donc est ce que tout le monde
pourra dire n'importe quoi
moi je trouve qu un exemple assez
intéressant c'est l'exemple du slip
français donc tout le monde a entendu
parler ces dernières semaines avec des
salariés qui ont mis sur des réseaux
sociaux des des contenus qu'ils ont été
confondus qui sont considérés manière
dans l'opinion publique comme des
contenus racistes
la question qui se pose c'est est-ce qu
effectivement les la plateforme devront
elles retirent ronsin elle aurait
certainement sous l'égide de la loi
retiré ce contenu est-ce qu'elle aurait
aussi retirer l'ensemble des
commentaires qui se sont acquis qui se
sont posés en réaction à ce contenu
peut-être il y aurait peut-être
finalement eu un débat très limité sur
le sujet alors le texte prévoit
également la création d'un parquet
spécialisé dans la lutte contre les
propos haineux qui sera désigné par le
ministère de la justice après l'entrée
en vigueur de la loi
pourquoi la création d'un tel parc et
intervient maintenant et est ce que on
peut être tranquille en termes
d'indépendance alors le texte prévoit
d'abord là
mination d'un observatoire qui va faire
un certain nombre de préconisations et
effectivement disposer d'un parquet
spécialisé comme on a un parc et anti
criminalité
c'est quelque chose qui peut avoir du
sens dans un contexte particulier avec
dédé internet qui va très vite
d finalement des atteintes qu'ils
prennent tout de suite une qui se
démultiplie à une vitesse pas possible
et effectivement avoir un avoir un des
organes judiciaires qu'ils puissent
qu'ils puissent qu'ils puissent avoir
une connaissance importante des outils
et des règles de fonctionnement peut
éventuellement être utile alors on se
rend compte évidemment quand on vous
écoute parler
et voilà on a eu beaucoup d'invités qui
critiquaient cette loi que lutter contre
la cyber haine c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement compliqué elle que dans le
fond on est impuissant à ce qu'il ya de
vraies solutions aujourd'hui
en fait on est ce qu'on est impuissant
encore une fois tout va très vite on
utilise
j'ai l'impression l'ensemble des acteurs
du marché pour aider à lutter parce que
via les circuits traditionnels ça prend
du temps et mettre à contribution ses
plateformes ça peut être utile après les
plateformes sont pas nécessairement ravi
d'être mis à contribution et d'avoir une
loi qui leur imposant un délai très bref
contre des sanctions extrêmement
importante de devoir retirer ses
contenus merci vanessa à bouchard un
avocat spécialiste en droit de la
propriété intellectuelle d'avoir été
avec nous en dira les errances autre
projet de loi qui fait l'actualité
aujourd'hui le texte sur la bioéthique
examiné lui au sénat ils permettent je
vous le rappelle aux femmes seules et
aux couples de lesbiennes l'ouverture à
la pma la procréation médicalement
assistée ce nouvel arsenal législatif a
été validé par l'assemblée nationale en
octobre il est débattue au palais du
luxembourg ont jusqu'au 4 février avant
de repartir en deuxième lecture au
palais-bourbon
il mesure sociétal emblématique promise
par emmanuel macron mais contesté par
une partie de l'opposition à droite
notamment écouter justement la vie
et de sénateurs et de la ministre de la
justice au micro d'rtl je pense qu'il
faut que l'on avance il faut simplement
que l'on prenne toutes les garanties
permettant d'éviter les dérives et donc
c'est pour ça qu'il ya un certain nombre
d'abonnements qui ont été déposés au
sénat et qui m'aident être prises en
considération et donc notamment sur
l'avancement de la recherche etc
enfin les le cadrage la recherche pour
les boutiques lambaye n'importe où je
suis pour la prima j'ai déposé trois
fois déjà ce texte dans mon
l'ancien mandat de mon mandat précédent
je suis aussi bien sûr pour la le
remboursement de la fin on va sur la gpa
j'ai certaines considérations qui
m'empêchent l'accepter mais en même
temps je dis que les enfants nés par gpa
il faut les inscrire nous avons fait des
propositions lors du débat à l'assemblée
nationale en première lecture pour
ouvrir de nouveaux droits qui sont le
corollaire de l'ouverture de la pma nous
avons trouvé une solution qui je crois
est équilibré et donc je souhaite
entendre le sénat sur ces sujets là
j'espère que ils pourront rester dans la
même solution que celle que nous avons
proposé mais en tout cas je serai
attentive ce qui pourra être dit sur ce
sujet dans quelques instants rester avec
nous nous irons aux états unis où le
procès en destitution de donald trump a
commencé le locataire de la maison
blanche le qualifie depuis davos de
farce puis nous reviendrons sur la
nouvelle composition du gouvernement
russe dévoiler tout à l'heure
[Musique]
loïc et geoffroy de la tulle et sont
deux frères explorateurs animés par une
passion commune l'eau
[Musique]
pour leur cinquième expédition ils ont
choisi de sillonner l'amérique du sud en
side-car à la rencontre des populations
locales
[Musique]
en cinq mois de la vie de sao paulo a
soif et à la terre de feu
inhabitée ils ont parcouru plus de 14
mille kilomètres motivés par cette
question
notre usage de l'eau témoins utiles de
notre lien à la nature
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs se jouer mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
je suis l'ex maire et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france d'avant la
société afghane ne permet pas aux femmes
d'être libres comme les hommes les
hommes peuvent faire ce qu'ils veulent
mais pas les femmes
[Musique]
nous avons encore besoin d'un garçon en
tout cas j'ai sept filles et pas de fils
en fait seuls les pays qui viennent chez
nous et qui joue avec elles savent que
c'est une fille dehors quand elle joue
avec une balle
personne ne s'en rend compte que c'est
une fille et tout le monde croit que
c'est un garçon
pour
[Musique]
m
les news de stars est jeune mais c'est
votre soutien que nous apprécions le
plus
[Musique]
nous devons entre la glace trouver un
emplacement sur la banqueroute et y
établir un campement ensuite on dérive
rassure ce bloc de glace
en gros nous mettons au point un nouveau
type de station le navire et la glace
comme une infrastructure unique c'est
notre maison pour les prochains jours
peut-être même les prochains mois alors
préparez-vous à dériver les études de
l'atmosphère est robosphère la couche
limite héliosphère sont très différentes
aux latitudes polaire nous allons
enregistrer la température la salinité
la pression on va mesurer les flux les
vitesses les directions les
caractéristiques et drôle physique
non non pas le câble
j'ai envie de courir partout pour
annoncer que la banquise s'est fissurée
asus vient là voilages l'avoir c'est
celle qui est juste devant la maison
d'un côté il y avait des maisons et de
l'autre des pavillons avec les
équipements je n'avais pas peur parce
que je ne savais pas de quoi il fallait
avoir peur le lac le plus vieux du monde
les lacs n'ont généralement pas plus de
quinze mille ans
ical à plus de 25 millions d'années
ici vivent des esprits et des divinités
bouddhiste
l'eau pure et transparente du lac aide
les scientifiques à résoudre des
mystères de l'univers
je vois le baïkal comme un ensemble
cohérent je ne savais pas à quoi
m'attendre ici ce n'est pas que je
découvre quelque chose de nouveau ici je
m'imprègne simplement de tout ce qu'il y
a
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir merci nous rejoindre en direct
sur arte france pour cette deuxième
heure d'information tout de suite voici
les titres de l'actualité
c'est parti pour le procès historique en
destitution de donald trump pour abus de
pouvoir et obstruction un procès sans
accusé puisque le président américain à
lui et à davos pour assister au forum
économique mondial
les démocrates dénoncent un calendrier
imposé pourra quitter au plus vite le
président des états unis rouquine a
dévoilé la composition du nouveau
gouvernement russe les poids lourds
sergueï lavrov et sergueï choïgou
conservent leur portefeuille des
affaires étrangères et de la défense
le président russe a souhaité le succès
est la nouvelle équipe dirigée par
mireille michaud steen
[Musique]
le procès historique de donald trump
vient donc de débuter à washington avec
l'ouverture des débats au sénat alors
que républicains et démocrates
s'affrontent sur des questions de
procédure le président américain n'est
pas présent au procès il est embourbé au
coeur d'un scandale un coup de téléphone
en juillet dernier à son homologue
ukrainien dans celui-ci l'aurait demandé
une enquête sur joe biden son adversaire
démocrate les précisions sur place de
doha abdelrazik est bien les yeux de
l'amérique mais aussi du monde sont
rivés vers le congrès le capitole plus
précisément le siège du congrès ici à
washington où se déroule ce procès en
destitution de donald trump stapro c'est
historique c'est le troisième président
de l'histoire des états unis à se
retrouver confronté à cette procédure d'
impeachment vous l'avais dit au coeur de
la faire un coup de fil donald trump
aurait demandé à son homologue ukrainien
est bien de l'aider à discréditer son
potentiel rival à la présidentielle joe
biden en échange de l'octroi d'une aide
militaire alors il faut savoir que la
bataille s'annonce féroce au vu de ce
qui s'est passé il y environ une heure
car il faut savoir que cette procédure
de destitution va se dérouler en
plusieurs étapes
aujourd'hui en fait les sénateurs
doivent déterminer le calendrier des
débats comment cette procédure va avoir
lieu dans les prochains jours il y a
donc 100 sénateurs qui sont présents des
démocrates mais aussi des républicains
et hier soir et bien les républicains
ont présenté la procédure à suivre
à savoir deux blocs de 12 heures pour
l'accusation mais aussi autant pour la
défense puis viendra autour des
questions des sénateurs
mais cette procédure elle fait déjà
débat les démocrates ne veulent pas ils
jugent ce temps beaucoup trop court le
procès pourrait ainsi être bouclée en
deux semaines
donald trump lui est accusé par la
chambre des représentants d' abus de
pouvoir et entrave à la bonne marche du
congrès donc ça sera la première étape
aujourd'hui à savoir donc le calendrier
qui va fixer les règles du jeu puis
viendra ensuite la phase concernant les
témoins celle ci se fera par vote
les démocrates veulent que plusieurs
témoins assistent à ce procès un vote
qui n'inquiète pas donald trump qui
n'inquiète pas d'ailleurs le président
américain tout court à ce procès puisque
vous l'avez dit donald trump est
actuellement à davos où il assiste au
forum économique mondial
il a une nouvelle fois qualifié ce
procès de chasse aux sorcières de farce
mais le démocrate
adam schiff qui porte justement
l'accusation va tout faire pour essayer
d'allonger la procédure de ce projet de
ce procès par exemple pardon qui se
déroule un petit peu plus longtemps
donc nous allons suivre de près
aujourd'hui ses débats au congrès et
puis nous verrons demain comment vont
s'organiser et bien cette accusation
avec les témoins qui devrait comparaître
à ce procès en destitution de donald
trump le leader des démocrates au sénat
américain chuck schubert s'est exprimé
tout à l'heure il a prononcé un discours
très virulent envers donald trump
écouter ses actions du président sont
des crimes contre la démocratie
elle-même
il est difficile d'imaginer une plus
grande subversion de notre démocratie
que l'intervention de puissances
étrangères pour déterminer l'issue
d'élections sur notre territoire
qu'un pays étranger temps une telle
chose de lui même est déjà assez
préoccupant mais qu'un président
américain sollicite délibérément une
telle chose et fasse chanter un pays
étranger en lui proposant une assistance
militaire en échange de son aide pour
remporter une élection est infiniment
pire
je ne peux imaginer aucun autre
président faire cela les avocats de
données appelé hier le sénat américain
je cite à quitter immédiatement le 45e
président des états unis
retour en images sur les principales
caractéristiques de ce procès historique
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis washington avec ben swan
journaliste journaliste d'investigation
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir bonsoir ben soit merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france ce
soir lors tout d'abord quelques
impressions sur l'atmosphère qui règne
aux états unis avec l'ouverture de ce
procès est ce que c'est le feuilleton
que tout le monde va suivre
en l'absence à on le précise de donald
trump qui a préféré se rendre à davos
je pense que ça va être le feuilleton le
plus ennuyant qu'on puisse imaginer en
raison parce que nous savons déjà
comment cela va se terminer en fin de
compte se rendra compte que les
républicains et le sénat américains ne
vont pas considérer le président
coupable de cette api pouvoir et de
cette entrave au congrès et ils vont le
quitter en fin de compte il serait
presque impossible qu'il y ait une autre
issue
la véritable question devient donc
quelles seront les événements entre
temps avant d'arriver à cette conclusion
que tout le monde connaît la réalité
c'est qu'on ne sait même pas ce qui va
arriver
mitch mcconnell le chef du sénat le
dirigeant de la majorité déjà mises en
place la possibilité de mettre un terme
au procès avec un vote c'est qu'il est
prêt donc si ils perdent le contrôle si
des témoins sont appelés qu'il n'aime
pas s'il décide de mettre un terme au
procès il peut immédiatement
donc il n'y aura pas beaucoup de
surprises car il a mis en place des
garde-fous pensons assuré alors il y
aura pas beaucoup de surprises et vous
prédisez un feuilleton pas très
intéressant il n'empêche
est-ce que selon vous il pourrait quand
même y avoir un impact sur la
présidentielle si l'on n'apprend d'être
deux trois choses qui pourrait ne pas
plaire vraiment au peuple américain ça
vous semble possible
je pense que c'est très peu probable
il est très peu probable que nous
apprenons quelque chose de nouveau
lorsque la chambre des représentants a
introduit ses chefs d'inculpation les
démocrates qui étaient en contrôle ont
essayé de déterminer si le président
avait commis des crimes mais voilà ce
que cela pas de vraiment étonnant
pour la première fois de l'histoire des
états unis nous commençons un procès en
destitution au sénat sans avoir de
véritables chefs d'inculpation de
véritables crimes l'entravent au congrès
et l'abus de pouvoir sont les deux chefs
d'inculpation mais ce ne sont pas des
crimes public l'auditoire le peuple
américain a déjà pris ses décisions
certains démocrates ont déjà leur propre
vision pense que le président a tort des
républicains pensent que le président a
raison à cela ne va pas changer les
indépendants qui sont encore dans la
terre maman pense que la procédure est
fosses qu'au niveau de la chambre c'est
elle et c'était les démocrates qui a
buzzé de la procédure est maintenant au
niveau du sénat et les républicains
les deux parties sont malhonnêtes le
disent pas la vérité
pour beaucoup d'américains il n'y a plus
aucun d'intérêt pour le procès alors
justement oui les démocrates a accusé
les républicains de vouloir organiser un
procès en destitution je cite truqués de
donald trump ans au sénat avec un
calendrier imposé distille pourra
quitter au plus vite le président des
états unis est ce que c'est le cas quand
même
effectivement qui veulent se débarrasser
de cela plus rapidement possible l'une
des questions c'est de savoir s'il y
aura des témoins et cela fait partie de
ces événements qui pourrait ne pas
arriver du tout et ne poser aucun
problème
les sénateurs évoque l'idée de témoins
les démocrates donne une liste de
témoins tels que l'ancien ambassadeur le
l'ancien secrétaire d'état aux affaires
de sécurité john bolton bus ne va ni le
chef de cabinet de la maison blanche
ils veulent que ces personnes mais on a
déjà dit qu'elles ne pourront pas
témoigné dirai combien dis bien si vous
appelez c'était moi nous voulons
interroger et joe biden et son fils
hunter baden qui sont au centre de cette
affaire de coups de téléphone au
président de l'ukraine
les démocrates ne veulent pas que c'est
et monde parle donc il y à un débat sur
qui appelait qui viendra mais on
certaines personnes disent qu'il n'y
aurait peut-être pas du tout de témoins
donc en fin de compte ce que le sénat
veut c'est que cette situation soit
résolue aussi vite que possible parce
que les républicains pensent qu'ils ont
déjà gagné
les démocrates sont allés trop loin et
le public ne les suit pas et les
sondages semblent indiquer cela le
public n'est pas très intéressé par
cette procédure de destitution
mais en même temps à un sondage tout
récent indique que 57 % les américains
disent que toute preuve de la chambre
des représentants devrait être présenté
lors du procès parce que il semblerait
que le sénat ne permettrait même pas de
nouvelles preuves
la situation est si
partisane qu'aucun des partis des
considéré comme étant francs et on ne
sait pas à qui faire confiance
est ce que c'est pour cette raison que
vous décrivez que finalement donald
trump lui il semble très sûr de lui il
est partir à davos avec toujours le même
discours
une farce une chasse aux sorcières on se
souvient qu'à l'époque ans n'était pas
du tout la même chose mais bill clinton
lui s'était excusé il avait dit qu'il
était désolé
donald trump s'est pas du tout la même
musique un ace qui la raison finalement
été que donald trump qu'on apprécie ou
non est certainement très bien très bon
très doué s'agissant de contrôler les
médias et de contrôler son image il
clinton a menti sous serment et
effectivement il s'était excusé pour
cela ils espéraient et susciter
l'empathie tout naturel a construit
toute sa présidence sur sur sa volonté
sans honte de dire je ne m'excuse pour
rien je suis un homme qui force et je ne
m'excuse jamais finale trump en allant à
davos est très stratégique
il parle de l'économie américaine il
parle aux autres dirigeants américains
il
c est l âge de son manque d'inquiétude
il ne veut surtout pas qu'à washington
on le pense inquiets de ce qui pourrait
se passer au cours de ce procès il veut
montrer qu'il n'a aucune inquiétude et
qui n'a rien à craindre car il n'a rien
fait de mal voilà ce qu'il dit je pense
que c'était une décision intelligente de
contraste et davos et ce qui se passe au
sénat parce que si donald trump semble
faire son travail pour le peuple et d'un
cela va à l'encontre de ce qui se passe
à washington
merci beaucoup benz one journée les
investigations d'avoir été avec nous en
direct ce soir pour notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur merci à vous
on connaît depuis 18 heures heure
française le visage de nouveau
gouvernement russe 12 ministres au total
qui conservent leur poste
à l'instar des poids lourds sergueï
lavrov et sergueï choïgou mais on compte
aussi du sang neuf le point avec antoine
gayraud c'est le président russe
vladimir poutine qui a ouvert inauguré
en compagnie de son premier ministre
mirail michou steen ce conseil des
ministres nouvelle génération il a
commencé par féliciter les nouveaux
venus pour leur nomination
tout en rendant hommage au travail
fourni par la précédente équipe un
travail qu'il faudra désormais
poursuivre le gouvernement précédent a
fait beaucoup pour poursuivre le
développement premièrement les
conditions macroéconomiques ont été
instaurées et ça c'est très important
et bien évidemment sans cela il n'y
aurait aucun résultat après tout ce qui
a été obtenu grâce à un travail
important et doit être exploitée pour
l'avenir
pour parvenir au résultat d'intérêt
national et utiliser les instruments qui
était un construit qui ont été mises en
place notamment pour les grands projets
donc le précédent gouvernement à
travailler là dessus il a mis en place
des instruments qui sont utiles
j'ai seuls ceux là encore une fois va
donc l'intérêt du pays et la priorité
c'est bien évidemment du d'améliorer le
bien-être de la population et tout cela
ce sont des objectifs qui sont tout à
fait réalistes
encore une fois je vous souhaite bonne
chance et je suis convaincu que vous
ferez tout votre possible pour que nous
puissions parvenir aux objectifs qui ont
été fixés parmi les ministres à avoir
conservé leur portefeuille on dénombre
sergueï lavrov aux affaires étrangères
ou encore sergueï choïgou à la défense
c'est donc la continuité qui a été
préféré pour ces deux ministères aussi
important que sensible autres ministres
à avoir déjà été présents dans le
gouvernement précédent alexandre novak à
l'énergie qui va
continuez de superviser l'achèvement de
la construction du gazoduc north stream
ii ou encore le renouvellement des
différents contrats gaziers parmi les
nouvelles têtes
on peut citer oleg matinaux ministère
des sports qui pour sa part hérite du
dossier épineux des accusations de
dopage à l'encontre du sport russe ou
encore maxime reshetnikov qui remplace
maxime orechkine à l'économie c'est donc
un savant mélange d'expérience et de
nouveautés de continuité et de
renouvellement qui se retrouvent dès
aujourd'hui à devoir gouverner la russie
et le chef de la diplomatie russe
sergueï lavrov garde donc ses fonctions
le ministre des affaires étrangères
avait été nommé en 2004 à ce poste
stratégique diplomate respecté par ses
pairs il a été mis en première ligne
dans nos nombreuses négociations
délicates sur la scène internationale
notamment dans les dossiers du nucléaire
iranien et du conflit syrien on revient
sur son parcours avec françois xavier
lambert il est l'une des principales
voix de la russie sur la scène
internationale depuis ses 16 dernières
années
né en 1950 dans la capitale russe
sergueï lavrov est issu d'une famille
arménienne
diplômé de l'institut d'état des
relations internationales de moscou à la
fin des années 1960 il va rapidement
démarré son ascension au sein de la
diplomatie soviétique sergueï lavrov
devient premier secrétaire de la mission
de l'urss aux nations unies à partir de
1981 puis devient le représentant
permanent de la russie à l'onu en 1994
il y restera dix ans pendant ces années
onusienne sergueï lavrov est décrit par
ses collègues comme un redoutable
négociateur inflexible et qui défend
coûte que coûte la position de son pays
nous réagirons de manière pragmatique
pas comme des petits garçons qui offense
et claque la porte s'enfuit de la classe
et se met à pleurer dans un coin les
relations internationales se sont
établies sur le principe de réciprocité
on a ce que l'on mérite autant de
qualités qui vont le conduire à devenir
le ministre des affaires étrangères de
la fédération de russie en 2004 à la
manoeuvre sur tous les grands dossiers à
commencer par le conflit syrien
après avoir obtenu le démantèlement de
l'armement chimiques de damas en 2013
il accuse à plusieurs reprises
l'occident de soutenir des groupes
terroristes value mcev pas trop d'eau
nous sommes très préoccupés par la façon
dont certains de nos partenaires
occidentaux ont changé leur
compréhension même de la terreur si ils
disent que le terrorisme en syrie doit
être arrêté mais cela est impossible
temps qu'assad est au pouvoir
ce match o'neal au sol cela signifie
qu'ils écartent le principe fondamental
et universel que le terrorisme est
totalement injustifiable
en fait ils essaient de trouver des
excuses aux terroristes et de lancer des
ultimatums
une stratégie qui fait le jeu des
partisans du terrorisme en syrie secouée
[Musique]
sergueï lavrov et également lors des
principaux artisans de l'accord sur le
nucléaire iranien signé en 2015 un texte
qu'il défend bec et ongles
malgré le retrait américain de l'accord
en 2010 809 euros sauf sauf pour nos
positions sur la plupart des questions
qu un si doux sont très proches bien
entendu la situation autour du plan
d'action global commun sur la résolution
du programme nucléaire iranien était au
centre de la discussion
nous avons réaffirmé notre ferme
engagement à maintenir cet accord
crucial qui a été approuvée par une
résolution du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies les tensions avec les
occidentaux le conduisent également a
accusé l'otan de restaurer une
atmosphère de guerre froide avec la
russie souveraineté rejet de l'ingérence
dans les affaires des autres et à
égalité des peuples respect mutuel la
russie a toujours respecter ces
principes dans ses relations
internationales et continuera de les
défendre au cours des 25 dernières
années notre pays malgré les difficultés
a fait sa part du contrat concernant
l'élimination du patrimoine de la guerre
froide et a fait beaucoup pour renforcer
la confiance et la compréhension dans la
zone euro atlantique et dans le monde
sergueï lavrov reste donc à son poste
une continuité qui devrait permettre à
la russie de peser dans les nombreux
dossiers cruciaux pour l'avenir de la
planète et pour en parler nous sommes
avec aplomb blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison une réaction sur ce
nouveau gouvernement on garde les mêmes
sur la scène internationale et on change
pour la gestion peut-être davantage al
interne de la virus je crois qu on garde
les mêmes qu'en ce qui concerne les
poids lourds si vous voulez puisqu'en
effet sergueï lavrov et et le visage de
la de la russie la diplomatie russe à
l'extérieur et ils restent là mais on
garde aussi monsieur chose vous qui est
le ministre de la défense et qui avant
cela était ministre des situations
d'urgence c'était lui qui était sur
toutes les zones de catastrophe
avec les groupes spécialisés pour
traiter ces problèmes
donc c'est aussi quelqu'un qui pèse
lourd dans le gouvernement russe est
d'ailleurs le ministre des situations
d'urgence est également maintenu dans
ses fonctions
ce qui est important sur le plan
intérieur russe et puis les grands
ministres économiques restent en place
sully et d'offres est reste vice premier
ministre et ministre des finances le
ministre de l'industrie ministre du
commerce reste en place
les grands ministres sectoriels comme le
miz agriculture reste en place
est ce son que comme vous disiez les
ministres sociaux qu'ils ont à faire
avec les préoccupations quotidiennes des
gens la santé l'éducation la culture qui
changent et probablement que là en effet
il y avait une demande de la société
russe pour voir un changement et voir
des politiques plus dynamique et plus
ouverte dans ces secteurs
alors autre changement peut
blanchemaison nouveau ministre pour les
sports oleg ma titine en remplacement de
pévèle kolobkov changements nécessaires
fait alors qu'on le sait la russie est
mise au banc mondiale en raison de ce
vaste scandale autour
ni dommage on avait remarqué que le
ministre sortant disait circulez ya rien
à voir
en matière de dopage alors c'est pas ce
que dit le chef de l' agence russe
lagence russe de contrôle du dopage qui
lui a dit à plusieurs reprises qu'il
fallait peut-être faire le ménage dans
certaines des fédérations sportives et
je pense que c'est cela qui fait que à
nouveau ministre des sports arrive qui
vient d'ailleurs des milieux
universitaires et qui sera pour le
rendre plus ouvert au dialogue notamment
avec le chef de son agence de lutte
contre le dopage puisque la demande
évidemment de la masse et que la russie
s'engage sérieusement et que ces
fédérations sportives son regard est
sérieusement dans la lutte contre le
dopage de manière à ce que tous les
sportifs russes puissent concourir dans
les grandes compétitions internationales
alors je veux la jouer rien à voir c'est
que en regardant l'image
vous voyez tout à l'heure des ministres
autour de du premier ministre il y avait
assez peu de fabre je suis pas sûr que
on s'approche de la parité j'ai même le
sentiment qu'on a un petit peu moins que
le gouvernement précédent
alors bien sûr il faut des gens
compétents mais je pense qu'en russie il
ya aussi beaucoup de femmes compétentes
absolument et on en a d'ailleurs ici
chez arte je me parlez pas de près de 6
l'avenir de vladimir poutine dans tout
simple blanchemaison vous avez un petit
peu surpris avec cette annonce la
réforme de la constitution comment vous
le voyez son avenir au président russe
je crois qu il
n'est pas encore prêt sur lui-même il a
ouvert plusieurs portes il en a fermé
une île à fermer celle de ceux qui
consistait à faire une réforme de la
constitution pour pouvoir se représenter
un troisième mandat consécutif sa hiver
cartes et cette hypothèse et il a ouvert
d'autres possibilités par la réforme
alors certains disent peut-être premier
ministre si la majorité de la douma
futur le lui demandait ou bien président
d'un conseil d'état complètement
renouvelé complètement réformé ou bien
inspirateur et chef du parti politique
dominant russie unie
ce qui est sûr c'est que tous les gens
qui le connaissent disent qu'il restera
dans le paysage d'une manière ou d'une
autre que ses partisans comme ses
adversaires considère aussi qu'il
restera dans le paysage alors ses
partisans le souhaite ardemment et sont
inquiets ses adversaires le redoute mais
il pense aussi qu'ils restent pas dans
le paysage là dessus un consensus merci
claude manche maison expert en relations
internationales d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt français dans quelques
instants nous reviendrons sur la coupure
d'électricité géante qui a touché ce
matin le sud de paris dans le secteur
précisément de rungis et d'orly une
action revendiquée par la cgt énergie
qui annonce d'autres actions de ce type
jusqu'à vendredi à l'assemblée nationale
edouard philippe a condamné cet acte et
demande des sanctions de recevront
justement une cégétiste qui viendra se
justifier nous expliquer en tout cas sur
ce plateau
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent la
haine en soi vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche qui est
extrêmement tous les témoins de notre
époque sont dans la grande interview
[Musique]
les news ne s'arrête jamais mais c'est
votre soutien que nous apprécions le
plus
[Musique]
il y a une problématique d'augmentation
extrêmement importante de la demande en
eau depuis la révolution verte qui a
conduit à cette autosuffisance
alimentaire de l'inde dans ces zones
climatiques aride il ya quasiment plus
d'eau en surface
on compte maintenant à peu près sur le
pays de l'ordre de 25 millions depuis
pomper ce qui est six fois plus que la
chine
cette image une femme qui porte un pot à
eau sur la tête et une image que l'on
voit partout pour les femmes c'est une
charge énorme des petites filles peuvent
pas aller à l'école parce qu'elles
doivent aider à cette tâche par exemple
donc ça accentue des inégalités 85% de
l'eau consommée
en inde les par l'agriculture c'est un
des premiers exportateurs de blé de riz
des peas qui consomment énormément d'eau
pour être produite à l'échelle mondiale
d'eau virtuelle c'est à dire l'eau qui
est contenu dans les produits qui sont
échangées l'inde est un des plus gros
exportateurs d'eau donc c'est un
paradoxe le reçoit
ils sont élevés dans un seul but
ils ont un super pouvoir il commence à
s'entraîner dès le plus jeune âge
huit mois de formation intense
ce sont des rats et il sauve des vies
humaines
les chefs-d'oeuvre de la peinture sont
comme des livres ouverts sur les siècles
passés
les contempler ces découvrir le regard
que portent les artistes sur leur époque
[Musique]
oh
il est un thème qui a toujours eu une
place à part dans l'histoire de l'art
c'est celui de l'enfance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que le regard de l'artiste a changé
entre cet enfant iconique peint sous les
traits de jésus par jean fouquet et sept
enfants couverts de toute la tendresse
de sa mère peint par elisabeth vigée
lebrun
entre le regard triste de cette jeune
fille contraint de vendre ses charmes
dans les rues de londres et
l'insouciance de cet enfant à qui le
suisse félix vallotton donne la liberté
de ne même pas regardé le peintre
de l'allemand dürer aux flamands
revendiquent de l'espagnol velasquez au
moderne renoir miro et picasso à travers
toute l'europe du moyen âge au 20e
siècle les grands maîtres de la peinture
n'ont cessé de représenter des enfants
selon les canons de leur époque
[Musique]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france merci de nous rejoindre alors
que la lutte contre la réforme des
retraites se poursuit
les relations se tendent entre les
syndicats ont fait le point avec
grégoire douce et la fracture semble
consommé ce lundi une nouvelle intrusion
a eu lieu au siège de la cfdt
d'après la confédération une quinzaine
d'individus encagoulés sont venus couper
l'électricité durant quelques minutes
une action revendiquée par des syndicats
cgt énergie d'île de france
berger négocié les couleurs et les
formes de nos futures chaînes et celle
de nos enfants sans jamais avoir
participé à la grève reconductible
contre la retraite à points
cet incident intervient après une
première intrusion vendredi dernier
qualifiée de violente par laurent berger
le patron de la cfdt
quelques dizaines d'individus se sont
introduits violemment dans les locaux de
la confédération cfdt ce midi ils ont
agressé verbalement et physiquement des
salariés de la cfdt
nous condamnons cet acte et nous ne nous
laisserons pas intimider
la cfdt cible des critiques de plusieurs
syndicats depuis qu'elle a accepté le
compromis proposé par l'exécutif sur la
controversée réforme des retraites
une plainte a été déposée par
l'organisation réformiste qui a
également publié un communiqué la cfdt
poursuivra son combat pour plus de
justice sociale et de solidarité entre
les travailleurs sans jamais se laisser
dicter ses positions par des actes de
violence ou d'intimidation
de son côté le secrétaire général de la
cgt philippe martinez a tenu à condamner
ces actions nous condamnons toute forme
de violence
mais pour être très clair il y en a
marre du cgt bashing nous n'avons pas à
porter le chapeau de tout ce qui se
passe dans le pays dès qu'il ya un
problème on cible les militants de la
cgt alors que le projet de réforme des
retraites est toujours au coeur des
débats
le climat entre les syndicats se
refroidit nettement sur fond d'intense
divergences et pour en parler nous
sommes avec marie claire cailletaud
dirigeante confédéral cgt bonsoir marie
claire cailletaud merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france on vient de voir
ce sujet
résumé de la situation la cfdt ciblé par
deux intrusions en quatre jours
revendiquée par votre centrale la cgt
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
aujourd'hui que c'est vraiment
démocratique comme action est ce que
vous comprenez les critiques que cela
suscite
alors tout d'abord vous venez de dire
que c'est revendiquée par les centrales
ce qui n'est pas le cas
revendiquer en tout cas parole cité non
non je veux dire laissez passer à cdt a
été revendiqué par quelques syndicats
qui ont fait cette action mais n'ont pas
été revendiqués par la fédération et par
la confédération
d'ailleurs la confédération a fait un
communiqué pour dire qu'elle
n'approuvait pas ce genre d'actions
donc ce qui s'est passé avec la cfdt
pour moi n'aurait pas dû avoir lieu
maintenant il faut pas que les médias
j'allais dire en face non plus plus dans
cette affaire-là
c'est un épiphénomène moi j'allais dire
laissons les adhérents de la cfdt régler
leur problème c'est à dire qu'on est ce
qu'ils considèrent que la cfdt est un
allié objectif du gouvernement est ce
qu'il défend les travailleurs mais
j'allais dire nous il faut pas qu'on se
détournent de notre combat aujourd'hui
qui est le combat contre la réforme des
retraites et pour cela il faut qu'on
arrive à élargir encore plus le
mouvement qui n'est aujourd'hui c'est à
dire à faire en sorte que le 24 il y
encore plus de gens dans la rue dans
l'action et dans la grève
marie kaka était au pardon de rebondir
là dessus tout de même aimé c'est vrai
que c'est intéressant parce que je pense
que beaucoup de français ont
certainement fait l'erreur parce qu on
lit partout revendiquée par la cgt alors
voilà ce sont vous les dires des quand
même des personnes qui se revendique
de la cgt donc il y a un problème
peut-être de sémantique ou de
compréhension
voilà du fonctionnement peut-être de
votre centrale mais c'est imprécis
important de s'arrêter quelques instants
là dessus parce qu'on on lit partout que
ça a été tout simplement revendiquer
clairement notamment on parlera des
coupures de courant mais revendiquées
par la cgt énergie
la cfdt voit c'est que ça a été
revendiqué clairement par des cégétistes
qu'il assume maintenant mais ça a été
revendiqué par des syndicats de la cgt
énergie mais les mots ont leur
importance
et oui fait de montrer tandis qu'on en a
rigolé par la société pour maturité
c'est la confédération cgt aujourd'hui
chez l'entente dirigeante de la
confédération cgt on veut dire et la
confédération cgt a fait un communiqué
hier soir pour dire qu'elle soutenait
les électriciens gaziers en grève
qu'elle se battait pour la réforme mais
qu'elle désapprouvait l'intrusion qui
s'est passé hier à la cfdt qui s'est
traduit quand il faut le dire par une
coupure de courant d'une minute
mais bon qui n'aurait pas dû avoir lieu
donc très clairement la cgt était clair
là dessus donc ça a été revendiquée par
les syndicats de l'énergie qui ont fait
cette action très bien voici qui est
clair on parle beaucoup ici ou là
d'intimidation est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec justement ce mot puisque
les mots ont un sens aujourd'hui
beaucoup critiquent un manque de
démocratie de la part de certains
membres de la cgt est ce que vous
trouvez cela injuste mais vous savez on
sent beaucoup de choses monte
aujourd'hui dans le débat effectivement
intimidations
voyez des choses comme ça moi je pense
qu'effectivement le mouvement ce temps
parce que le gouvernement se rend compte
edouard philippe à la bouche pleine du
mot démocratie il en a il a encore usé
au cet après midi à l'assemblée
nationale
moi j'allais dit on n'a pas de leçon de
démocratie à recevoir de quelqu'un qui
passe en force sur un projet de loi qui
est quand même aujourd'hui rejeté par
une majorité de syndicats je le rappelle
qui représente une majorité de salariés
un mouvement qui est soutenu pour une
majorité de la population
donc on sent que le gouvernement étant
quand même en difficulté parce que
beaucoup de gens ils sont plus en plus
nombreux ont compris que ce projet de la
retraite n'allait pas concerné que les
régimes spéciaux mais allait concerner
tout le monde et y compris les femmes
même peut-être les retraités donc ça les
précariser tout le monde donc je prends
qu'il ya une prise de conscience et
d'ailleurs on le voit au fur et à mesure
des sondages qui s'opère et donc le
gouvernement est en difficulté par
rapport à ça alors oui il faut mettre
dans le débat intimidations
radicalisation des termes comme ça que
je désapprouve pareil comme edouard
philippe par le coupures sauvages
moi je sais pas ce que c'est je sais pas
ce que c'est qu'une coupure sauvage
enfin vouloir qui me l'esprit qu'un
écoutons edouard philippe à l'assemblée
nationale aujourd'hui vouloir bloquer un
certain nombre de sites ne pas respecter
la loi
en s'introduisant dans telle ou telle
enceinte privée procéder à des coupures
sauvages de courant tout cela tout cela
c'est méconnaître la démocratie tout
cela c'est méconnaître la loi et tout
cela doit être sanctionné car ça n'est
pas acceptable ça n'est pas acceptable
monsieur le député vous le savez
parfaitement
l'outil de production ils se respectent
le service public ils se respectent nos
concitoyens ils se respectent
lorsqu'on procède à des grèves lorsqu'on
procède par don à des coupures sauvages
d'électricité ont met nécessairement nos
concitoyens les usagers du service
public dans une situation qui est
parfois périlleux voilà edouard fini
qu'il fait référence à cette vaste 1
pour le coup coupures d'électricité qui
a touché ce matin le sud de paris et
revendiquer clairement par la cgt
énergie vous pensez que ça peut
justement vous avez dit clairement vous
ne cautionnez pas forcément ce type
d'action à ce que sap notre attention ce
qu'on cause qu'on n'a pas cautionné
c'est l' intrusion chez la cfdt
par contre ce genre d'action il est
clairement revendiquée par la fédération
quand on fait grève à un moment donné
qu'est ce qu'on fait on se retire du
travail
on reprend main son outil de travail je
vais rappeler que les salariés des
industries nautiques et gazière ils sont
en grève depuis à peu près très
fortement depuis le début du mouvement
depuis début décembre il y avait encore
trente mille grévistes la semaine
dernière c'est quand même très important
il ya eu des baisses de charges de 12000
mega bass sur le réseau c'est la
consommation d'une fois et demie la
région parisienne donc c'est aussi des
choses qu'on n'avait pas fait depuis des
années et des années
ils font des actions qui sont certes
beaucoup moins médiatique comme la
remise de courant aux personnes en
précarité énergétique je rappelle qu'en
france il ya 13 millions de personnes en
précarité énergétique que c'est un
chiffre qui augmente alors effectivement
ils font des coupures mais c'est pas des
coupures sauvages ne sais pas ce que
c'est qu'une coupure sauvage
ils font des coupures ciblées ça veut
dire qu'ils décident en assemblée
générale du personnel d'aller couper à
des endroits pour exprimer leur
mécontentement et en général ils coupent
des endroits de production ils coupent
des choses de ce type là alors c'est
vrai que quand on fait des coupures
souvent il ya quelques dégâts
collatéraux c'est à dire qu'à parfois
des partis qui sont coupés on essaye de
faire qu'ils soient couverts moins
longtemps possible mais moi son
échantillon de j'entends le discours du
déterminisme avec ce que j'entends dans
le discours du premier ministre
c'est un on respecte l'outil de
production moi je peux vous assurer que
les salariés qui font ça ils respectent
leur outil de production et ils font ça
dans les règles de l'art avec toutes les
règles de sécurité donc
quand le premier ministre dit qui met
les gens en insécurité ça veut dire
qu'il connaît pas ce qui est en train de
se passer
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
quand il parle du service public alors
là j'ai envie de dire ça me ferait
presque rigoler parce que le service
public de l'énergie ce qui lui ont
vraiment chevillée au corps c'est les
salariés et en particulier la cgt vous
savez historiquement la cgt on est à
l'origine de la création de df et gdf on
en est très fiers du service public de
l'énergie
or qu'est-ce qui s'est passé c'est que
les gouvernements successifs et en
particulier des gouvernements du bord
auquel appartient à monsieur philippe
ont complètement privatiser ce secteur
par exemple aujourd'hui vous n'avez plus
de services publics du gaz gdf a disparu
pour être privatisé avec une fusion avec
suez
aujourd'hui c'est edf qui est dans le
collimateur quand il était ministre
l'économie emmanuel macron avait en tête
de coupe et edf en morceaux il n'a pas
pu le faire maintenant qu'elle est
présente la république
il veut couper edf un morceau c'est à
dire que c'est la fin du service public
de l'électricité
il veut privatiser les barrages
hydrauliques donc entendre un premier
ministre aujourd'hui nous parler de
service public est d'usagé
excusez moi mais il devrait avoir quand
même un peu plus de modestie là dessus
mais aujourd'hui est ce que vous dites
finalement ce qu'on fait c'est peut-être
illégal mais on n'a pas le choix pour
nous faire entendre aujourd'hui parce
que ça reste illégal ses actions ce que
les actions qui sont faites
elles sont décidées par des salariés qui
sont en grève qui se réunissent en
assemblée générale c'est comme ça que ça
se passe
c'est pas dans un bureau quelque part on
dit vous est d'appuyer sur un bouton
c'est à dire que les salariés qui sont
en grève il décide de leur mode d'action
et nous là je dire ce qu'on veut ce
qu'on leur dit c'est qu'il faut que
toujours ses actions et soit décider
collectivement par les gens qui sont en
grève et qu'elles soient assumés
collectivement et c'est ce qui se passe
à l'heure actuelle je pense pas qu'ils
aient de mise en danger de personne mais
par contre oui ça c'est clair que ça
agit sur l'économie quand on coupe des
centres commerciaux quand on coupe des
usines quand on coupe oui il est certain
que ça agit sur l'économie mais si vous
voulez le gouvernement le gouvernement
il a fait le
le jeu du rapport de force et de laisser
le mouvement pourrir donc qu'est-ce que
vous voulez que fassent les salariés les
salariés ça fait déjà ça fera demain 50
jours que certains sont dans l'action 50
jours qui sont en grève
je le redis ce projet de réforme il est
soutenu il est rejeté par une majorité
de syndicats qui représentent une
majorité de salariés et l'opinion
publique ne veut pas non plus le
mouvement est encore soutenue malgré
tout ce qui peut se dire majoritairement
par la population donc il ya un
véritable problème démocratique il faut
que le gouvernement
il accepte de faire une pause et de
rentrer vraiment en négociation en
négociation ça veut dire qu'on dit pas
venez et puis vous rentrez dans une
boîte et vous en sortez pas c'est à dire
que par exemple sur le financement des
retraites
on n'a pas le droit de parler de
l'augmentation des cotisations sociales
on n'a pas le droit de parler
voyez donc la seule solution qui nous
donne en sortie c d'augmentation de
l'âge de la retraite donc c'est
complètement un marché de dupes
donc on est un gouvernement qui n'écoute
pas et qui n'entend pas donc ça mène à
des situations qui sont effectivement
tendue et difficile mais très
sincèrement on a rarement eu un
gouvernement de ce type là quoi il n'a
pas de de connaissances sociales
il n'a pas d'assise sociale et moi je
suis désolé de le dire mais tous les
députés qui sont dans sa majorité sont
des gens qui sont assis au sol donc
aujourd'hui clairement ce climat
extrêmement tendue est liée à ce
gouvernement mais kron dont on est
nicolas sarkozy pardonnez moi
l'expression fanfaronner un peu avec
humour hier en disant moi j'ai fait
passer plein de grandes choses sans un
bruit dans la rue et enfin c'est pas ses
mots mais bref sans qui une contestation
est ce que c'est vraiment le cas et
surtout est-ce que c'est lié selon voies
emmanuel macron et à son gouvernement
si vous voulez je pense que emmanuel
macron accrue quand il est arrivé au
poste du président de la république qui
pouvait se passer des syndicats y
compris de tous qui on appelle moi
j'aime pas trop ce terme et les corps
intermédiaires
donc il a voulu jouer en direct avec le
peuple entre guillemets aussi parce
qu'il faut se serrer très sain débat
aussi et donc ça lui revient en
boomerang dans la figure j'allais dire
un il a eu le mouvement et gilet jaune
moi je pense qu'on en a tiré aucune
leçon il il a cru se sortir du mouvement
des gilet jaune avec un grand débat mais
moi j'ai envie de vous dire qu est ce qu
a donné le grand débat aujourd'hui
qui peut me dire quels ont été les
mesures qui sont sortis du grand débat
donc résultat le mouvement des gilet
jaune
il n'est pas terminée je veux dire on
sent bien que le mécontentement il est
là tant est qu'il revient d'ailleurs
c'est une bonne chose que dans le
mouvement aujourd'hui contre la retraite
on trouve des gens qui ont manifesté sur
les ronds-points parce qu'on s'est rendu
compte assez rapidement que sur les
ronds-points leurs revendications des
gens et rejoignez beaucoup celle que
l'on portait nous hein c'est l
augmentation des salaires c'était plus
de service public c'était pouvoir finir
les fins de mois
donc finalement que des gens comme eux
et comme nous on se retrouve c'est une
très bonne chose donc effectivement le
comportement du présent la république
avec tout son gouvernement
j'allais dire excusez moi mais ce sont
des clones quoi ce sont des clauses
ministériel
ils ont tous eu l'information et sortent
tous du même endroit ils peuvent ils
sont incapables de comprendre ce qui se
passe effectivement par exemple sur un
rond point est ce qu'aujourd'hui
finalement le problème n'est pas plus
profond n'est pas tout simplement au
niveau de la représentativité et notre
vème république
emmanuel macron l'avait dit qu'ils
feraient cette réforme des retraites
alors pas l'âge pivot ça c'est vrai mais
le système universel à point il l'avait
dit il a été élu est ce que c'est parce
que justement il n'est pas assez bien
élu comme d'ailleurs ça a été le cas
certainement pour les prédécesseurs pour
françois hollande pour qui a eu aussi un
score qui n'étaient pas très élevées ce
que c'est pas ça le fond du problème
finalement aujourd'hui qui ne contente
pas assez
ce qui est très clair c'est de toute
façon emmanuel macron a pas été bien ému
parce qu'enfin vous savez comme moi la
condition dans lequel il a été élu à mon
avis d'ailleurs y joue un jeu dangereux
parce qu'ils en train d'essayer de
refaire le même scénario pour la
prochaine élection présidentielle
mais enfin emmanuel macron je crois
qu'au premier tour c'est 24% quand même
des voix qu'il a et au deuxième tour
c'est pas forcément un vote d'adhésion
c'est surtout un vote de rejet
or beaucoup de gens ont voté manuel
macron sans vouloir son système de
retraite par points donc vouloir
s'appuyer que je vous dit certainement
attendu les ventes activision entendu
mais c'est un problème aujourd'hui
moi j'allais dire un monde où sa
retraite elle est rejetée donc posant la
question posée la question fut dire
merci en tout cas à marie claire
cailletaud d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france dirigeant
confédéral cgt
merci et alors que la france vit au
rythme des grèves à on vient d'en parler
contre cette réforme des retraites
l'hôpital public restent mobilisés lui
aussi un collectif de parents se bat
pour la défense des urgences
pédiatriques en ile-de-france katia
technique il faut sauver la réanimation
pédiatrique les services d'urgence qui
accueille les enfants en danger de mort
un cri d'alarmé a été lancée par des
citoyens des parents qui se mobilisent
contre la fermeture des lits dans les
urgences pédiatriques d'île de france
cet hiver faute de place 25 enfants ont
dû être transférés hors d'île de france
à rouen amiens lille orléans une
situation inacceptable que dénonce
l'appel des parents de l'area
pédiatrique qui a lancé une pétition
destinée au président de la république
et agnès buzyn la ministre de la santé
vous mettez à 5000 signatures ya un peu
moins de 10 jours et qu'aujourd'hui on
vise les 159 85 secondes
ce jeune couple a eu recours aux
services des urgences pédiatriques
durant de longs mois pour deux de ses
bébés lors de sa grossesse sophie a été
hospitalisé et risque est de perdre sa
fille mais faute de lits le service l'a
pressé de rentrer chez elle j'ai
déclenché un hématome heures est trop
placentaire à à 29 semaines de grossesse
et à ce moment là si je
j'ai écouté justement le personnel
soignant qui me préconisait de rentrer
chez moi comme on a une demi heure pour
intervenir sinon le bébé n'est plus
oxygéné clairement romy n'aurait pas
survécu
la décision des médecins n'étaient pas
un débat n'est pas d'une décision de
médecine vraiment mais été subies par
des choix administratif de l'hôpital
ses parents qui ont connu l'angoissé du
transfert pour leur nouveau-né dénonce
les transports d'enfants dont la vie ne
tient qu'à un fil un enfant qui est
entre la vie et la mort peut rester
coincée dans des embouteillages
il peut très bien avoir un accident il
ya plein de paramètres qui peuvent faire
que la vie de l'enfant est vraiment en
danger et on accroît ses risques en
faisant ce genre de transfert donc c'est
inadmissible aujourd'hui le collectif se
bat pour venir en aide aux personnels
qui sont entrés en grève des mains 2019
pour réclamer davantage dans bausch
notre deuxième enfant elle a clairement
été sauvés par leur activité par par le
service des urgences pédiatriques et de
la réanimation
s'il avait fallu à déplacer s'il y avait
eu la moindre défaillance
en fait elle a juste pas survécu
beaucoup ça ne paraît évident
aujourd'hui de porter un peu la voix des
parents parce que c'est une urgence très
forte d'humaniser un petit peu de
secours de l'hôpital pour leur dire ce
qu'on risque aujourd'hui c'est la vie de
nos enfants et on doit informer
justement toute l'opinion publique et
leur dire que on attend des réponses de
la ministre agnès buzyn qui doit rendre
des comptes aux familles cet hiver
quelques lits ont été rouverts à paris
et l' agence régionale de santé a mis en
place une réunion de suivi quotidienne
avec l'ap-hp afin d'éviter les
transferts
une situation que dénonce gerald kirneck
médecin urgentiste réanimateurs les
responsables des fermetures de lits ce
sont justement les rs ces fameuses
agences régionales de santé et le
ministère de la santé
en sept ans il ya eu plus de 17000 lee
qui ont été fermés en france
à l'assistance publique-hôpitaux de
paris gare à paris il ya 900 lits qui
sont fermés en fait il ya deux raisons
il ya un les le manque de personnel et
on est un espèce de cercle vicieux pas
de personnel pas de lit les deuxièmement
il ya une vraie volonté technocratique
administratifs bureaucratiques donc de
la rs des agences régionales de santé de
fermer les livres
donc moi ça me fait doucement rigoler
comme mes collègues entre la rs10 oui on
va mettre en place un comité de suivi
etc
ce sont eux et responsable la fermeture
des lits alors que 1200 médecins ont
démissionné collectivement de leurs
fonctions administratives le 14 janvier
la ministre de la santé va t'elle un
corps d davantage de moyens à l'hôpital
public dont toutes les futures crack les
gaffes à l'ordre du jour entre paris et
washington idem à l'assemblée nationale
vidée de sa substance par le sénat en
décembre après l'échec de la commission
mixte paritaire du 8 janvier
la loi vient contre la haine en ligne
fait son retour au palais bourbon
certains députés s'interrogent encore
sur l'utilité de ce texte
voilà aussi pour faire taire l'opinion
mais vous savez c'est un pouvoir faible
autocratique malsain qui divisait
français et qui s'aiment
qui sème le vent et qui récolte la
tempête et c'est malsain pour le pays
moi je souhaite qu'on apaise les choses
et et c'est terrible ce qui se passe
mais il ya un moment un autre bain on en
sortira mais dans quel état
dans quel état le pays ou celles plus
tristes et pour le pays dans tout ça
c'est pas nous on va s'abstenir sur
cette loi la majorité du groupe vaut
s'abstenir
moi je la trouve pas si mauvaise mais
c'est vrai qu'elles comportent des
dangers et en plus je crois qu'elles
soient inutilisables car d'abord elle
est très belle et très compliqué je suis
pas sûr que les gars fin
jouent le jeu complètement je tue patio
candé suffisamment de magistrats pour
juger et là on risque de tomber dans une
suite une suite de problèmes qu'on
n'arrivera pas à régler c'est une loi
dans l'intention est bonne mais dont la
réalisation est mauvaise moi je
m'abstiendrai sur ce texte parce que
j'ai le sentiment qu'il ya une intention
de vouloir faire les choses mais vous
savez très bien qu'une directive
européenne qui doit intervenir
majoritairement le groupe liberté et
territoires vote raconte moi je
m'abstiendrai pourquoi parce qu'on peut
pas laisser des façon impunie au titre
de la liberté d'expression laissé
proférer n'importe quel type de message
voilà et là tu reconnaissons le il ya
une forme d'impuissance public
incapacité à faire en sorte que on
arrête ces propos un jour antisémite
deuxième jour appelant au terrorisme le
troisième jour je ne sais pas quoi
encore ou vraiment c'est la haine et la
violence qui est véhiculée au quotidien
la réponse doit être judiciaire mais
elle est pas suffisamment judiciaire et
pour vanessa bouchard avocate
spécialiste en droit de la propriété
intellectuelle cette loi manque pour
l'instant de précisions qu'est ce qu'on
appelle contenu qui qui est susceptible
d'être considérée comme et ne sait tout
ce qui est contenu susceptible de porter
atteinte à la dignité humaine donc on a
un grand nombre de 2,2 de choses qui
rentrent dans cette acception et dans
ces conditions ça veut dire que de
manière très large les plateformes
auront une obligation de bloquer des
contenus qui seront susceptibles d'une
manière ou d'une autre de porter
atteinte à la dignité humaine qui est
essentiel et qui est un qui est quelque
chose de fondamental on met à la charge
des plateformes une un délai extrêmement
court pour bloquer un certain nombre de
contenus selon des critères qui sont
parfois peu défini et ça peut ça peut
créer une sorte de d'incertitude et
l'incertitude n'est jamais
jamais n'est jamais sécurisante pour les
différents acteurs du marché très
direction des bosses à présent souvent
le forum économique mondial au menu de
ce sommet la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique pourtant ce
rendez-vous est contestée notamment par
les ong écologistes t au combat le monde
est en état d'urgence
la fenêtre pour agir est étroite c'est
par ces mots que le fondateur du forum
de davos klaus schwab a ouvert cette 50e
réunion économique mondiale l'événement
a en effet été placé sous le signe des
enjeux environnementaux présentée comme
prioritaires pour cela les organisateurs
ont décidé d'inviter certaines figures
du mouvement de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique comme la
zambienne natacha moins de ça ou encore
la suédoise greta tanberg presque rien
n'a été fait contre le réchauffement
climatique qui sont des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre ne sont pas réduites
ce que je veux dire c'est que nous
luttons tous pour le climat et si vous
regardez depuis cet aspect ce qui a été
concrètement fait en la matière si vous
changez de perspectives il n'y a presque
rien de ce que nous attendions cela
requiert beaucoup plus que cela ce n'est
vraiment que le commencement
une situation paradoxale pour un forum
auquel est très souvent accolé
l'étiquette de club des riches
l'an passé la conférence avait par
exemple engendré près de 1500 vols de
jets privés autour de la célèbre station
suisse autre point noir
l'accueil de plusieurs dirigeants
d'entreprises finançant ou exploitants
des énergies fossiles
c'est le cas du pdg de total patrick
pouyanné tout le discours paraît bien
loin des aspirations des ong
environnementales
il faudrait que tout le monde retombe un
peu sur terre sur ce sujet énergétique
je ne verrai pas de mon vivant un
système énergétique à base uniquement de
renouvelables il faudrait quand même
qu'on arrête de rêver tous
collectivement selon greenpeace au moins
dix banques régulièrement présente au
forum économique mondial
honte à elle seule financer entre 2015
et 2018
le secteur des énergies fossiles pour
près de 1000 milliards
dollars en dépit des avertissements ils
alimentent une nouvelle crise financière
globale
en soutenant l'industrie des énergies
fossiles ces financiers ne sont rien
moins qu hypocrite en disant qu'ils
veulent sauver la planète alors qu'il la
tue pour un profit à court terme
cette année les organisateurs du sommet
ont annoncé que les personnalités
officielles seront transportés en
limousine électrique et ont fortement
recommandé la marche pour se rendre au
forum et lors de cette première journée
au forum économique mondial de davos des
activistes du climat se sont rassemblés
dans la ville suisse ils ont en profité
pour accuser le président américain de
négationnistes du climat donald trump
qui a annoncé aujourd'hui qu'il allait
soutenir un ambitieux projet du forum
économique mondial
il consiste à planter milla milliards
d'arbres dans le monde d'ici 2030 une
annonce accueillie avec scepticisme par
les manifestants qui ont pris la parole
afin de critiquer les grands dirigeants
de la planète
[Applaudissements]
ils profitent
l'économie est déterminé par ceux qui
réalisent des profits pas parce qu'ils
en paient le prix
la démocratie signifie que chaque
personne concernée par une décision a le
droit de participer à cette prise de
décision indépendamment de la taille de
leurs portefeuilles
indépendamment du fait qu'il soit
propriétaire d'une entreprise ou d'un
groupe
aujourd'hui nous en sommes loin notre
système économique n'est pas
démocratique
les élites politiques discutent de la
façon dont elles vont diviser le monde
entre elle et nous les mortels nous
sommes ici c'est la fin de cette édition
se retrouve dans 5 minutes pour 1 point
complet sur l'actualité
[Musique]
oui
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
natation assez les chiens nordiques
j'irai donc ocean race husky de sibérie
qu'est ce qu'ils représentent pour vous
ces chiens améliore présente ce plein de
choses parce que c'est de l'amour de
l'amour au quotidien je chassais pas une
motoneige c'est pas une machine c'est
pour vous faire plaisir bien souvent qui
courent chaque chine a son caractère
il ya certaines de mes chiennes avec
lequel elle règne par le regard on
arrive à se comprendre
cette année on a fait un parcours à
l'envers arrivé un moment depuis des
années enfin à gauche
cette année elle nous a fait prendre la
piste par la droite mais comment alors
la chienne de tête à s'est retourné et
m'a dit tu es sur ton coup parce que
c'est pas par là qu'il faut aller
c'est d'autre côté
[Musique]
les blanchons les bébés phoques du
groenland naissent sur la banquise de la
mer blanche
tout au long du xxème siècle les bébés
phoques ont été chassés pour leur
fourrure blanche comme neige
depuis que la chasse aux phoques est
interdite en russie il n'y a que les
touristes qui viennent voir ces animaux
à l'état sauvage
mais ces petits seront ils toujours en
sécurité
[Musique]
les news ne s'arrête jamais mais c'est
votre soutien que nous apprécions le
plus
[Musique]
je m'appelle jean biart j'ai 18 ans je
crois en effet d'entraînement
on va leur enseigner leur show c'est
l'école d'arts martiaux du temple de
shaolin
et le ça fait trois fois que je te le
dis tu ne comprends pas où tu vas
t'entraîner tout seul
[Musique]
encore une fois c'est pas bon comme si
c'était la première fois en chou à se
tourner encore lépi le font mieux croit
en toi et tu réussiras
[Musique]
vladimir poutine vient de dévoiler la
composition du nouveau gouvernement
russe les poids lourds sacs et les profs
et sergueï choïgou conservent leur
portefeuille des affaires étrangères et
de la défense
le président russe a souhaité le succès
la nouvelle équipe dirigée par mira m
c'est parti pour le procès historique en
destitution de donald trump aura plus de
pouvoir et obstruction les débats sont
ouverts bosser sans accuser puisque le
président américain est à davos pour
assister au forum économique mondial et
démocrates dénoncent un calendrier
imposé pour recruter au plus vite le
président des états unis
la loi contre la cyber m et 3 assemblée
nationale sénat et retour au palais beau
bourg pour ce texte pour la science dont
la mesure la plus polémique a été
réintroduite il s'agit de
médiation pour les réseaux sociaux de
retirer sous 24 heures les conclut il
sous peine d'amendé
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous rejoignent et
bienvenue sur rt france on connaît
depuis 18 heures heure française le
visage du nouveau gouvernement russe
douze ministres au total conservent leur
poste à l'instar des poids lourds
sergueï lavrov et sergueï choïgou mais
on compte aussi du sang neuf le point
avec antoine claireaux c'est le
président russe vladimir poutine qui a
ouvert inauguré en compagnie de son
premier ministre michail michou steen ce
conseil des ministres nouvelle
génération il a commencé par féliciter
les nouveaux venus pour leur nomination
tout en rendant hommage au travail
fourni par la précédente équipe un
travail qu'il faudra désormais
poursuivre le gouvernement précédent
fait beaucoup pour poursuivre le
développement premièrement les
conditions macroéconomiques ont été
instaurées et ça c'est très important
et bien évidemment son cela il n'y
aurait aucun résultat après tout ce qui
a été obtenu grâce à un travail
important et doit être exploitée pour
l'avenir
pour parvenir au résultat d'intérêt
national et utiliser les instruments
qu'ils étaient construits qui ont été
mises en place notamment pour les grands
projets donc le précédent gouvernement à
travailler là dessus il a mis en place
des instruments qui sont utiles et seuls
ceux là encore une fois va dans
l'intérêt du pays et la priorité c'est
bien évidemment du d'améliorer le
bien-être de la population et tout cela
ce sont des objectifs qui sont tout à
fait réalistes
encore une fois je vous souhaite bonne
chance et je suis convaincu que vous
ferez tout votre possible pour que nous
puissions parvenir aux objectifs qui ont
été fixés parmi les ministres à avoir
conservé leur portefeuille on dénombre
sergueï lavrov aux affaires étrangères
ou encore sergueï choïgou à la défense
c'est donc la continuité qui a été
préféré pour ces 2
mystère aussi important que sensible
autres ministres à avoir déjà été
présents dans le gouvernement précédent
alexandre novak à l'énergie qui va
pouvoir continuer de superviser
l'achèvement du dans la construction du
gazoduc north stream ii ou encore le
renouvellement des différents contrats
gaziers parmi les nouvelles têtes
on peut citer oleg matinaux ministère
des sports qui pour sa part hérite du
dossier épineux des accusations de
dopage à l'encontre du sport russe ou
encore maxime reshetnikov qui remplace
maxime orechkine à l'économie c'est donc
un savant mélange d'expérience et de
nouveautés de continuité et de
renouvellement qui se retrouvent dès
aujourd'hui à devoir gouverner la russie
et pour claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales ce nouveau
gouvernement ne sera que transitoire en
attendant les excuses les élections
législatives de 2000 21 qui
détermineront les compositions de la
dola alors c'est très important on voit
que les amendements étaient soumis très
rapidement après leurs annonces
allah
la douma et au haut conseil de la
fédération réunis il était donc
probablement près puisqu'ils sont
arrivés très rapidement ensuite à la
douma
ça veut dire que monsieur poutine veut
aller vite pour mener à bien cette
réforme constitutionnelle et puis le
contenu même de ces amendements
et bien c'est un contenu assez important
puisque après la réforme c'est la douma
qui va désigner le premier ministre et
qui va désigner chacun des membres du
gouvernement
ça veut dire que la douma qui va être
élu à l'automne 2021 donc dans 18 mois
aura de nouveaux pouvoirs et que c'est
elle qui aura la légitimité pour
désigner le premier ministre et le
gouvernement
ce qui me fait dire peut-être me soulage
démenti par les faits que le
gouvernement actuel est un gouvernement
de transition de transition entre le
dispositif actuel et le dispositif qui
sera mis en place par la nouvelle
constitution et qui sera effectif après
l'élection de la prochaine douma elle
est chef de la diplomatie russe sergueï
lavrov conserve donc son portefeuille
le ministre des affaires étrangères
avait été nommé en 2004 à ce poste
stratégique diplomate respecté par ses
pairs il a été en première ligne dans de
nombreuses négociations délicates sur la
scène internationale du dossier du
nucléaire iranien au conflit syrien on
revient sur son parcours avec françois
xavier lambert
il est l'une des principales voix de la
russie sur la scène internationale
depuis ses 16 dernières années
né en 1950 dans la capitale russe
sergueï lavrov est issu d'une famille
arménienne
diplômé de l'institut d'état des
relations internationales de moscou à la
fin des années 1960 il va rapidement
démarré son ascension au sein de la
diplomatie soviétique sergueï lavrov
devient premier secrétaire de la mission
de l'urss aux nations unies à partir de
1981 puis devient le représentant
permanent de la russie à l'onu en 1994
il y restera dix ans pendant ces années
onusienne sergueï lavrov est décrit par
ses collègues comme un redoutable
négociateur inflexible et qui défend
coûte que coûte la position de son pays
nous réagirons de manière pragmatique
pas comme des petits garçons qui offense
et claque la porte s'enfuit de la classe
et se met à pleurer dans un coin les
relations internationales se sont
établies sur le principe de réciprocité
on a ce que l'on mérite autant de
qualités qui vont le conduire à devenir
le ministre des affaires étrangères de
la fédération de russie en 2004 à la
manoeuvre sur tous les grands dossiers à
commencer par le conflit syrien
après avoir obtenu le démantèlement de
l'armement chimiques de damas en 2013 il
accuse à plusieurs reprises l'occident
de soutenir des groupes terroristes et
vendeurs trop dormir trois choses nous
sommes très préoccupés par la façon dont
certains de nos partenaires occidentaux
ont changé leur compréhension même de la
terreur iso si ils disent que le
terrorisme en syrie doit être arrêté
mais cela est impossible tant qu'à sa
dette au pouvoir pour sortir ce match de
haut niveau
seuls nice et blanc cela signifie qu'ils
écartent le principe fondamental et
universel que le terrorisme est
totalement injustifiable
en fait ils essaient de trouver des
excuses aux terroristes et de lancer les
ultimatums une stratégie qui fait le jeu
des partisans du terrorisme en syrie ce
qu a révélé ni sergueï lavrov et
également lors des principaux artisans
de l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien
signé en 2015 un texte qu'il défend bec
et ongles
malgré le retrait américain de l'accord
en 2000
18 cents à ce pauvre chou weight loss of
president of product nos positions sur
la plupart des questions qu un si doux
sont très proches
bien entendu la situation autour du plan
d'action global commun sur la résolution
du programme nucléaire iranien était au
centre de la discussion n'est programme
mais pas de semer le trouble
nous avons réaffirmé notre ferme
engagement à maintenir cet accord
crucial qui a été approuvée par une
résolution du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies studio les tensions avec
les occidentaux le conduit s'est
également a accusé l'otan de restaurer
une atmosphère de guerre froide avec la
russie souveraineté rejet de l'ingérence
dans les affaires des autres états et
ganic et des peuples respect mutuel la
russie a toujours respecter ces
principes dans ses relations
internationales et continuera de les
défendre au cours des 25 dernières
années notre pays malgré les difficultés
a fait sa part du contrat concernant
l'élimination du patrimoine de la guerre
froide et a fait beaucoup pour renforcer
la confiance et la compréhension dans la
zone euro atlantique et dans le maine et
sergueï lavrov reste donc à son poste
une continuité qui devrait permettre à
la russie de peser dans les nombreux
dossiers cruciaux pour l'avenir de la
planète
souvent présentée par la presse
internationale comme l'un des meilleurs
ministres des affaires étrangères est
aussi connu pour ses traits d'humour en
voici une sélection
jeune réseau dit oui à votre cause est
off car manar paletot bois les
solutionner beau rob simmons femme
simone
voilà 17 ans que 110 ans tu la sors mon
époux sera mis aux prises des chevaux
comme paint balls at elle préfère notre
[Rires]
gueule
oh
[Musique]
nous avons quatre ans et que les poses
de noyaux d'atomes
yves lainé à tombouctou birth high times
and monitoring au centre et shuttle caps
jeunesse organise noël kaki pragoise
départeme étaient ceux qui souhaitent
inciter nos postes pharma
jose états-unis à présent le procès
historique de donald trump qui vient de
débuter à washington avec l'ouverture
des débats au sénat alors que
républicains et démocrates s'affrontent
sur des questions de procédure le
président américain n'est pas présent au
procès au coeur des discussions une
conversation téléphonique en juillet
dernier entre donald trump et son
homologue ukrainien un échange au cours
duquel il aurait sollicité une enquête
sur joe biden son adversaire démocrate
plus de précision avec dora adèle rasic
notre envoyé spécial à washington un bon
soir à doha que peut-on déjà retenir des
premières heures de ce procès en
destitution à procès en destitution
historique une bataille qui s'annonce
féroce entre républicains et démocrates
le sénat s'est transformé tout
simplement en tribunal
quelques jours après avoir juré de
rendre justice de manière impartiale les
100 parlementaires qui composent ce
sénat se sont donc retrouvés ils ont
entamé leur audience autour d'une
bataille qui concerne la procédure qui
doit encadrer le déroulement de ce
procès alors je vous rappelle que donald
trump est accusé d'abus de pouvoir et
d'entravé à la bonne marche du congrès
dans la sphère ukrainienne est tout à
l'heure et bien les démocrates ont fait
vraiment pression sur le chef de la
majorité républicaine mitch mcconnell
qui a fini par lâcher du lest selon une
résolution l'accusation aura 24 heures
pour exposer ses arguments la défense
bénéficiera également du même taux le
tout en six jours maximum puis il y aura
16 heures qui seront consacrés aux
questions des sénateurs alors il faut
savoir que c'est plus de temps que ce
qui avait été initialement annoncée mais
pas assez pour les démocrates qui vont
certainement et bien demandé et
introduire plusieurs amendements pour
donner justement plus de temps au débat
mais également pour réclamer la
présentation de documents et la
convocation de témoins clef la question
épineuse des témoins sera d'ailleurs au
centre des débats
il faut savoir que tout de même ce
procès en destitution donald trump n'a
pas de quoi vraiment inquiéter le
président américain puisque lé sénat est
en majorité républicains 53 élus sur 100
sont républicains donc donald trump ne
devrait pas sauf surprise être destitué
en fait ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
les démocrates ont dans la tête
autre chose nous sommes à quelques mois
de l'élection présidentielle américaine
ils veulent avant tout mobiliser leur
électorat et présenter le président
américain sous un mauvais jour
le président américain qui comme vous
l'avez dit est en déplacement
actuellement à davos où il assiste au
forum économique mondial
il a réagi là une nouvelle fois qualifié
ce procès de chasse aux sorcières si
doha en direct donc de washington et les
leaders des démocrates au sénat
américain chuck show maire a prononcé un
discours très virulent envers donald
trump
de son côté le chef des républicains
appelé à une procédure équitable et ses
actions du président sont des crimes
contre la démocratie elle-même
il est difficile d'imaginer une plus
grande subversion de notre démocratie
que l'intervention de puissances
étrangères pour déterminer l'issue
d'élections sur notre territoire
qu'un pays étranger temps une telle
chose de lui même est déjà assez
préoccupant mais qu'un président
américain sollicite délibérément une
telle chose et fasse chanter un pays
étranger en lui proposant une assistance
militaire en échange de son aide pour
remporter une élection est infiniment
pire
je ne peux imaginer aucun autre
président faire cela
la chambre des représentants a choisi de
ne pas convoquer les témoins qu'elle
souhaitait car le sénat s'engage à
priori allait convoquer comme je le dis
depuis des semaines personne personne ne
dictera aux sénateurs des états unis la
façon dont le sénat doit procéder
la plupart d'entre eux lui sont décidés
à respecter la manière unanime et
bipartisane qui a prévalu lors du
précédent clinton nous lutterons contre
les influences extérieures en ce qui
concerne le bon déroulement des débats
dans cette procédure
les avocats de notre compte appelé hier
le sénat américain je cite à quitter
immédiatement le 45e président des états
unis retour en images sur les
principales caractéristiques de ce
procès historique
[Musique]
sam ont brodé républicaine singh friends
le président américain prépare une
contre offensive d'écouter la mer
citation de donald trump que j'ai jamais
entendu de ma vie en tout cas pendant
l'été présidence et ce n'est pas après
moi qu'ils en ont c'est après vous le
peuple américain les chaînes ont choisi
ses propres à ses propres règles
internes comme la maison de
représentants choisis ses propres règles
internes
si on va discuter entre eux pour ceux ci
ce qui est historique avec ce procès
c'est que à partir de maintenant tous
les présidents qu'ils soient démocrates
républicains indépendants quoiqu'il soit
pourront avoir des procès interminables
aux troupes il est dit n'est pas aussi
bête que les européens veulent bien le
poids ou les démocrates et le prépare
une contre offensive sur tout les toutes
tes attaques souligne qu'il a eu il a
subi depuis trois quatre ans il va il va
les renvoyer dans le dans le visage des
démocrates pressent qu'il a certainement
la tête à washington donald trump et au
forum économique de davos où il s'est
exprimé en fin de matinée il n'est pas à
l'audience aux etats unis ils dénoncent
depuis la suisse je suis une farce et
une chasse aux sorcières
nous sommes ici pour rencontrer les
leaders mondiaux les personnes les plus
importantes du monde et nous ramener des
contrats formidable aux états unis ils
sont tous ici pour voir ça je vais faire
un discours et nous allons bientôt
partir mais je pense que c'est très
important
le reste n'est qu'une farce c'est la
chasse aux sorcières qui dure depuis des
années
et franchement c'est honteux
et lors de cette première journée au
forum économique mondial de davos des
activistes du climat se sont rassemblés
dans la ville suisse ils en ont profité
pour accuser le président américain de
négationnistes du climat donald trump
qui a annoncé aujourd'hui qu'il allait
soutenir un ambitieux projet du forum
économique mondial ce projet consiste à
planter 1000 milliards d'arbres dans le
monde d'ici 2030 une annonce accueillie
avec scepticisme par les manifestants
qui ont pris la parole afin de critiquer
les grands dirigeants de la planète
il profite l'économie est déterminé par
ceux qui réalisent des profits pas parce
qu'ils en paient le prix
la démocratie signifie que chaque
personne concernée par une décision a le
droit de participer à cette prise de
décision indépendamment de la taille de
leurs portefeuilles
indépendamment du fait qu'il soit
propriétaire d'une entreprise ou d'un
groupe
aujourd'hui nous en sommes loin notre
système économique n'est pas
démocratique
les élites politiques discutent de la
façon dont elles vont diviser le monde
entre elles et nous il est mortel
nous sommes ici
un nouveau gouvernement au liban après
trois mois d'impasse politique un
renouvellement ministériel a été opérée
hassan diab le premier ministre libanais
désigné dirigera un gouvernement composé
de 20 membres
en attendant cette annonce des
manifestants se sont réunis au pied du
parlement est depuis le 17 octobre le
pays est secoué par d'importantes
manifestations les protestataires se
révoltent contre une classe politique
jugée incompétente et corrompu mais gaf
1 à l'ordre du jour à l'assemblée
nationale vidée de sa substance par le
sénat en décembre et après l'échec de la
commission mixte paritaire du 8 janvier
la loi avia contre la haine en ligne
fait son grand retour au palais bourbon
certains députés s'interrogent encore de
l'utilité du texte c'est une loi là
aussi pour faire taire l'opinion mais
vous savez c'est un pouvoir faible
autocratique malsain qui divisait
français et qui s'aiment
qui sème le vent et qui récolte la
tempête et c'est malsain pour le pays
moi je souhaite qu'on apaise les choses
et et c'est terrible ce qui se passe
mais il ya un moment ou un autre on en
sortira mais dans quel état
dans quel état le pays ou celles plus
tristes et pour le pays dans tout ça
c'est pas nous on va s'abstenir sur
cette loi la majorité du groupe vaut
s'abstenir
moi je la trouve pas si mauvaise mais
c'est vrai qu'elles comportent des
dangers et en plus je crois qu'elles
soient inutilisables car d'abord elle
est très belle et très compliqué je suis
pas sûr que les gars femmes jouent le
jeu complètement je tue patio connais
suffisamment de magistrats pour juger et
là on risque de tomber dans une suite
une suite de problèmes qu'on n'arrivera
pas à régler c'est une loi dans
l'intention est bonne mais dont la
réalisation est mauvaise moi je
m'abstiendrai sur ce texte parce que
j'ai le sentiment qu'il ya une intention
de vouloir faire les choses mais vous
savez très bien qu'ils aient directive
européenne qui doit intervenir
majoritairement le groupe liberté
territoire vote raconte moi je
m'abstiendrai pourquoi parce qu'on peut
pas laisser des façon impunie
au titre de la liberté d'expression
laissé proférer n'importe quel type de
message
voilà et là tu reconnaissons le il ya
une forme d'impuissance public
incapacité à faire en sorte que on
arrête ces propos un jour antisémite
deuxième jour appelant autorise le
troisième jour
je ne sais pas encore où vraiment c'est
la haine et la violence qui est
véhiculée au quotidien la réponse doit
être judiciaire mais allez pas
suffisamment j'ai du ciel et pour
vanessa bouchard avocate spécialiste en
droit de propriété intellectuelle cette
loi manque pour l'instant de précisions
qu'est ce qu'on appelle contenu qui est
susceptible d'être considérée comme et
ne sait tout ce qui est contenu
susceptible de porter atteinte à la
dignité humaine donc on a un grand
nombre de 2,2 de choses qui rentrent
dans cette acception et dans ces
conditions ça veut dire que de manière
très large les plateformes auront une
obligation de bloquer des contenus qui
seront susceptibles d'une manière ou
d'une autre de porter atteinte à la
dignité humaine qui est essentiel et qui
est un qui est quelque chose de
fondamental on met à la charge des
plateformes une un délai extrêmement
court pour bloquer un certain nombre de
contenus selon des critères qui sont
parfois peu défini et ça peut ça peut
créer une sorte de d'incertitude et
l'incertitude n'est jamais n'est jamais
n'est jamais sécurisant pour les
différents acteurs du marché et alors
que la lutte contre la réforme des
retraites se poursuit les relations se
tendent entre les syndicats ont fait le
point avec grégoire douce et la fracture
semble consommé ce lundi une nouvelle
intrusion a eu lieu au siège de la cfdt
d'après la confédération une quinzaine
d'individus encagoulés sont venus couper
l'électricité durant quelques minutes
une action revendiquée par des syndicats
cgt énergie d'île de france
berger négocié les couleurs et les
formes de nos futures chaînes et celle
de nos enfants sans jamais avoir
participé à la grève reconductible
contre la retraite à points
cet incident intervient après une
première intrusion vendredi dernier
qualifiée de violente par laurent berger
le patron de la cfdt
quelques dizaines d'individus se sont
introduits violemment dans les locaux de
la confédération cfdt ce midi ils ont
agressé verbalement et physiquement des
salariés de la cfdt
nous condamnons cet acte et nous ne nous
laisserons pas intimider
la cfdt cible des critiques de plusieurs
syndicats depuis qu'elle a accepté le
compromis proposé par l'exécutif sur la
controversée réforme des retraites
une plainte a été déposée par
l'organisation réformiste qui a
également publié un communiqué la cfdt
poursuivra son combat pour plus de
justice sociale et de solidarité entre
les travailleurs sans jamais se laisser
dicter ses positions par des actes de
violence ou d'intimidation
de son côté le secrétaire général de la
cgt philippe martinez a tenu à condamner
ces actions nous condamnons toute forme
de violence mais pour être très clair il
y en a marre du cgt bashing nous n'avons
pas à porter le chapeau de tout ce qui
se passe dans le pays dès qu'il ya un
problème on cible les militants de la
cgt alors que le projet de réforme des
retraites est toujours au coeur des
débats
le climat entre les syndicats se
refroidit nettement sur fond d'intense
divergences candidat indépendant à la
mairie de paris et tête de liste
parisienne parisien dans le 15e
arrondissement appelle lui à
l'apaisement le prénom république avait
annoncé la couleur pour ma campagne
présidentielle il avait dit qu'il
voulait une réforme des retraites donc
il a un mandat électoral pour la mettre
en oeuvre ce que l'on peut regretter
c'est que la méthode qui était adaptée a
conduit à sa tombe
aux cages et de tensions dans le pays le
président la république et son
gouvernement ont mis du temps mais ils
ont fini par abandonner ou reporter la
mesure de l'âge pivot qui était celle
qui cristallise et les colères dans le
secteur privé et reste le système dit
par points qui conduit à une
universalisation du système de retraites
donc cette réforme peut aller au bout ce
n'est pas encore fait souhaitons que
maintenant on retrouve surtout le calme
et l'apaisement parce que vous savez
pour les usagers notamment les
franciliens les usagers des transports
publics il soit le métro la sncf pour
tous les franciliens mais aussi pour
tous les français vraiment il ya un
ras-le-bol généralisé moi je sens les
gens tendu épuisé fatigué donc je leur
témoigne ma seule et réalité parce que
vraiment c'est très fatigant pour les
gens c'est grève qui dure qui dure qui
dure
je pense que les gens ont envie de
sortir de cette phase extrêmement
douloureuse ils comprennent on ait
besoin de faire des réformes
en revanche il s'interroge sur les
blocages qui sont suscitées par celle ci
ils savent pas s'ils doivent accusé
gouvernement accusé des syndicats je les
comprends parce que moi même souvent je
me demande qui est le vrai responsable
de tout cela mais comme tout le monde
j'ai envie qu'on retrouve du calme et de
l'apaisement et de l'ordre c'est la fin
de cette édition prochain rendez-vous
avec l'actualité demain 7h du matin
heure de paris excellente fin de nuit à
tous
[Musique]
le xeroderma pigmentosum c'est une
hypersensibilité aux rayons ultraviolets
en fait c'est une maladie génétique qui
est transmise par les deux parents donc
des deux parents sont porteurs sains de
la maladie ce qui transmet ce qu'ils
transmettent en fait alors à leurs
enfants des enfants ne peuvent pas
s'exposer au soleil
acial comment on pourrait résumer une
journée type de votre vie ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que il faut pas qu'ils
aient un millimètre de pau qui sera
exposée apporte ses gants ses vêtements
on leur met leur masque avec la visière
qui leur permet de regarder à
l'extérieur
une fois qu'ils y sont ma fille je veux
pas qu'elle ait une vie où elle reste
tout le temps à la maison c'est pas une
vie tu auras la vie comme tout le monde
et ça je ferai tout pour que ça soit le
cas
loïc et geoffroy de l'aftu les sont deux
frères explorateurs animés par une
passion commune l'eau
[Musique]
pour leur cinquième expédition ils ont
choisi de sillonner l'amérique du sud en
side-car à la rencontre des populations
locales
[Musique]
en cinq mois de la vie de sao paulo a
soif et à la terre de feu inhabitée ils
ont parcouru plus de 14 mille kilomètres
motivés par ces questions
visage de l'eau témoins utiles de notre
lien la nature
[Musique]
le
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions